ross coldheart is an australian
investigative journalist for programs
like 60 minutes and he's one of the few
acclaimed journalists to take the
phenomenon of ufos seriously his new
book in plain sight is an investigation
into ufos as well as ostensibly
impossible physics and is linked below
click on the timestamps if you'd like to
skip this intro for those of you who are
new to this podcast my name is kurt
jaimungle i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of what are
called theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as delineating the possible
connection consciousness has to the laws
of physics provided these laws exist at
all and are knowable to us i'm a callow
novice in this area and thus most of my
questions would be callow which is why i
generally turn it to the audience who
comprise people far more knowledgeable
on the topic of ufos than myself my
angle is with regard to theoretical
physics particularly unification and
with regard to consciousness some don't
have the time to watch a two-hour
podcast on the topic of ufos or a 2.5
hour podcast on not theory in quantum
field theory or a four hour podcast of
chris langan's ctmu or have time to
watch a seven hour video on the topic of
consciousness such as that with leo gura
which is why there's a second channel
called toe clippings it's essentially
shareable ingestible 2 minute to 15
minute bites the link to that channel is
in the description or you can search toe
clippings on youtube though be prepared
for the repugnancy that follows if you
enjoy engaging and witnessing real-time
conversation on the topics of physics
psychology consciousness and so on then
check the description for a link to the
discord and the subreddit there's also a
link to the patreon that is patreon.com
kurtjmungle as the patrons and the
sponsors are all that allow me to do
this full time it would be near
impossible for me to have conversations
with fidelity on the topics of loop
quantum gravity string theory geometric
unity is coming up at some point if not
for your support thank you and that link
again is patreon.com
with regard to sponsors there are three
the first sponsor is algo algo is an
end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stock outs
reduce returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of this podcast since near its
inception in fact amjad has a channel
now a podcast about artificial
intelligence and its connections to
business as well as consciousness so if
you like that then click on the link
below and subscribe to his podcast as by
doing so you're supporting this channel
as well the second sponsor is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of
mathematics science and engineering with
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world which
elevates math and science from something
to be feared to a delightful experience
of guided discovery you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear people say that
the standard model is predicated on u1
cross su-2 cross su-3 those are
technically lead groups visit
brilliant.org
tow t-o-e for free and get 20 off the
annual subscription i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons and i
think you'll be greatly surprised at the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had trouble
grocking the third sponsor is curiosity
stream now curiosity stream is
interesting it's like the netflix for
nerds or the disney plus for the
scientist in you or the hulu for history
buffs speaking on the topic of
consciousness and ufos there aren't many
places with quality documentaries on the
subject if you're endeavoring to learn
more about those topics curiosity stream
access and ancilla to that quest
furnishing a variety of documentaries on
consciousness and ufos i recommend you
watch stephen hawking's favorite places
which combines quite a few of the
interests of this channel namely the
unification quest in physics alien life
and artificial intelligence go to
curiositystream.com
toe that is t-o-e for unlimited access
to some of the world's top documentaries
and non-fiction series use the promo
code t-o-e to get 25 off the annual
subscription that amounts to just about
15
that's approximately one dollar per
month which trounces virtually any of
the other video streaming services the
link is below and do let me know what
you think of stephen hawking's favorite
places many of you have asked how to
support this channel without other
platforms like patreon and visiting the
sponsors such as curiositystream.comtoe
is one way to do that more on them later
thank you and enjoy this podcast with
ross coldheart
can you speak
oh no brown cow one two three four five
six seven eight nine okay so we'll go
live
okay if you can
hear
this see this
then type in senzu bean
senzu bean
so ross is this your first
item of the day or did you have some
other tasks you got to before this
it's my first item of the day i've just
rolled out of bed to be honest kurt and
uh have my my first my first coffee of
the day as well
great great great okay all right it
seems like we're live
so the first question comes from aaa
star trader
ross you've linked cattle mutilations to
uaps and
he's he's wondering if you have heard of
human mutilations potentially with
special force assistance
look there's a lot of claims uh i mean i
think the most substantive evidence that
i've seen today that substantiates that
there is indeed a danger for humans
posed by uaps is the kolaras brazil
incident
uh which my friend james fox the
filmmaker is currently investigating in
brazil
but um yes i i do think there's a link
between cattle mutilations and the
phenomenon whatever it is i don't know
i have been absolutely
swamped
with veterinarians
animal carers up and down the east coast
particularly in australia since i aired
the story of mick and judy cook who live
up near gimpy in far north queensland in
australia
and they've suffered i think they know
of the loss of 15 cattle but as far as i
know there's been no human
uh
woundings or or killings or whatever
in this part of the world and i i shake
my head as i say that because it just
sounds preposterous you know we're
talking about animals being mutilated
for some reason
and uh
i wish i could understand the phenomenon
i don't know what it is
but um i've seen up close uh
the kind of injuries that these animals
suffer
and they're not
injuries that can be caused by
a simple scalpel or even a
laser cutter or
all manner of things that you think
would be able to do that kind of
operation you're talking about
completely exsanguinated bloodless
animals
that sometimes within a few minutes are
found with key organs missing from their
bodies with no apparent disruption to
the other organs and
the one that really shocked me was a a
very well respected veterinarian in far
northern new south wales about 10 hours
north drive of where i live
and he told me that he was doing an
autopsy on a cow that was found dead in
a paddock
in a field and um he in order to do that
in a paddock in a field
the british term paddock yeah australian
but uh and he moved the two stomachs
to get to the third stomach
and then he discovered that the third
stomach wasn't there
and he sent me the autopsy records and
the photographs to show what
what he saw and
as he said to me he said ross i can't
think of any way
he says if anybody's ever done an
autopsy on a car that's how you do it
that's how you get to the third stomach
you have to lift aside the other two
stomachs
and he said
i've never seen anything quite like it
because when he got to that third cavity
it just it was empty something had
removed the stomach
and
there's an incredible mystery there and
i wrestled with it to be honest i
wrestled as a journalist with whether i
should link cattle mutilations to the
phenomenon but
so many people have contacted me since i
feel very much vindicated in terms of
making that decision i just can't
explain it but in terms of human
mutilation the ones that i do know of
are the brazil calaras case i've spoken
very haltingly with a spanish friend too
what was it spanish or portuguese she
speaks both but uh
she spoke to uh some military people
that uh uh
gave me a bit of a background on kolaris
and i'm really thrilled to hear that
james fox is now in
the town where a lot of this happened in
brazil and i'm really excited to see
what he comes out with with his film
alien alcoholic asks have you heard of
facilities that are housing live
aliens no
okay
now i have a question about those human
mutilations have you read robert dolan's
book on the different it's like a
taxonomy of aliens like a speciation
the
i have i have not you mean richard dolan
or uh uh yeah richard
yeah
uh no i haven't i've read a few books by
richard notably the two volumes of
national security state but um
i haven't read uh his taxonomy of ufo of
aliens no i haven't
the reason i'm asking is that he would
say there are different kinds so one is
a gray then the other
seems to be lizard one seems to be
human-esque
and i'm curious if the human mutilations
are tied to a specific type that is to
say are there friendlier types and
i don't know
kurt you you've got somebody who starts
i work on evidence you know i i i don't
even know if i accept that there are
reptilians or grays or whatever i mean i
haven't seen them so frankly i i i just
don't know whether to buy into that what
i can tell you is i accept that there is
a genuine mystery
that there is an anomalous
phenomenon that is manifesting itself to
humanity
uh it's now being detected by very high
tech sensor systems and the pentagon has
admitted it's real what they haven't
admitted when we're talking about human
mutilations is um cattle mutilations and
human mutilations but privately you know
people and also i noticed chris mellon
actually went on the record with me in
my documentary he he acknowledged for
example that mutilations were a
phenomenon that was real
um
but when it comes to taxonomy of aliens
i'm not there yet you know i'm not even
sure this is alien
there's a phenomenon
i'm not even sure i mean i've spoken to
friends who've told me that
that they have witnessed uh
uh
non-human
entities up close
uh i don't know i just don't know
and and really
uh i think you just you as a scientist
would understand this is i find it very
hard to believe anything until i've seen
multiple corroboration and um you know
verified experimentation to prove what
i'm seeing is real
because if you accept
that and this is the case if you accept
that the under secretary for the
department of defense was um
uh prepared for a briefing there was a
briefing prepared called which included
a series of power points and one of them
was slide nine
and on that slide it talked about how
the pentagon was advising or people
inside the pentagon were advising the
under secretary for the department of
defense
that whatever the phenomenon is
it is capable of manipulating human
perception and consciousness
and if you accept that
i mean i'm not detracting from the
claims that people are making about
seeing aliens or seeing life forms or
seeing entities of some kind
but if you accept that how do we know
what they're seeing is real
now i'm not saying it's all a
hallucination or an illusion you know
i've had some very angry
experiences or abductee claimants who
have jumped on me in the last few weeks
for supposedly criticizing their
experience i'm not but what i'm saying
is we have to approach this with a
reasonable degree of scientific
objectivity so i'm not yet ready to say
this is little green men or reptilians
or grays or
tall whites or whatever
i've spoken to people who claim to have
had these experiences but unless i can
verify them
this is the problem i have with a lot of
experience that claims i'm not in their
bedroom i mean i i had a conversation
with a guy who is
sorry was very very senior in the fbi
during my research
and i i expected to make this sort of
hard-headed
skeptic about the phenomenon
instead he told me that he woke up in
the middle of the night and he and his
wife were paralyzed and there were gray
big-headed big-eyed aliens sitting at
the end of the bed
and he told me this incredible account
and and trusted me to keep his name
confidential but he wanted me to know it
was real
and
i said to him but how do you know it was
real you know how do you know you
weren't in a
some kind of induced dream state
and uh he told me a few things that made
me think that maybe he was having a
genuine experience but
then i said to him well the phenomenon
is capable allegedly
reportedly of
manifesting itself in different ways to
humans in the 19th century when people
looked up in the sky and saw ufos they
were looking at flying airships flying
ships in the sky
in the book of ezekiel they described
winged chariots
you know there's been a phenomenon going
back thousands of years but how do we
know that whatever it is
it's not
manifesting itself to us in ways that
allow our brains to comprehend it
and manipulating our perception and
indeed our consciousness
that's the only question i ask when
people start talking about um
uh you know
taxonomy of aliens or whatever how do we
know what they're seeing is physically
what's there
speaking of how we know this question
comes from stan allister
it's a question i'm sure you've gotten
plenty of times and something you've
thought about yourself which is
there are many there are billions of
smartphones
why is it that there aren't clear videos
or clear photos
even though there are clear photos of
anomalous events let's say unexpected
events that are rare such as certain
meteorites
there's a few ways to answer that
question the first is that um he's
absolutely right
there should be more images there should
be more videos taken
but
one of the things that
i was struck by when i started looking
at the claims that have been made and
i've also spoken to people
in various three-letter agencies about
this
it is quite clear
that
the phenomenon is capable i think one of
the fab observables that uh louis
lozando described was that the
phenomenon is capable of remotely
interfering with human technology
and robert salas for example described
to me the minuteman missile launch
commander from the 1960s described to me
how
whatever the object was
it was able to manipulate remotely
the control systems for his icbm
missiles and shut them all down one by
one i've had conversations with people
in russia who told me about similar
things in russia but it was even more
frighteningly the other way
all of a sudden their missiles went up
online and were rolled ready ready for
launch literally one button push from
launch so something is capable of
remotely
affecting the
human technology
i know that's mind-boggling and as a
hard-headed journal i find it incredible
that i'm having these conversations but
this is what the pentagon has been
advised
this is the thing that i find
interesting is that a lot of the
skeptics and the debunkers have not yet
caught up with with all respect to them
the evidence that is being gathered to
show that the pentagon
is aware of things that this phenomenon
can do that cannot be explained by known
technologies
and so
coming back to the question
a human camera i would have thought
operates electromagnetically it's quite
clear that there are aspects to the
phenomenon that are
fundamentally electromagnetic is it
remotely possible that they are capable
of meddling with our technology that
they're capable of um
affecting our capacity to take good
photographs i've struck kurt by the
number of times that i've spoken to
people who've witnessed the phenomenon
up close
and i've said to them why the hell
didn't you take a photo you know you
were there you had a bloody camera
and they go you know that's weird i
it didn't occur to me
that has happened time and time again
and it's interesting because
there's a series of incidents up around
a place called north west cape a very
remote
military base in western australia
called the harold e holt naval
communications station which was an
american base until 1991
1992
and i've spoken to three people who've
witnessed the phenomenon in that part of
the world and each one of them describes
this kind of weird feeling where
they've actually forgotten about their
experience until in one case two years
later
nikolai the guy that i was talking to
was telling me that he'd seen a an
object by the side of the road like a
car standing on its end a big solid
oval that was clearly metallic of some
kind but glowing emitting some kind of
plasma glow
and he said he didn't even remember it
until two years after the fact
so i keep on coming back to the fact
that one of the things that we just have
to acknowledge is that the pentagon is
being advised
the u.s department of defense is being
advised by the people who know
from the office of the under secretary
of defense intelligence probably louis
lozando and his team while they were
working on atip but also other people
i'm advised including the uap task force
they're being advised that whatever this
phenomenon is
it's psycho
psychometric
psychotronic psychotronic weaponry it
has the capacity to meddle with our
minds and to middle with our technology
so i i don't think it's entirely outside
the realm of possibility that um cameras
are a bit of a doddle for um whatever it
is to interfere with
ross
speaking of meddling i'm curious of you
as a journalist maybe it's a selfish
question on my part by investigating
this phenomenon have you had the
government come to you and tell you to
speak or not speak about certain
subjects have you had your phones tapped
in any
have you had your emails
well emails are tapped to some degree
already but
i think you understand what i'm asking
yeah i don't understand miller dramatic
but i i think any journalist who does
the kind of work that i do i do a lot of
national security a lot of defense and a
lot of intelligence work i just
naturally assume that my phones are off
all the time that somebody's listening
one of the things that people need to
understand is that signal
which is an app that a lot of people use
in the belief that it's totally and
utterly safe is absolutely compromised
i know they'll dispute this but my
understanding is that the five eyes have
the capacity to
access the signal encrypted
communication system and probably all
the others for quite a few years
people who are interested in this should
read
a series of articles about the cia's
penetration of a company called crypto
aeg which was a um
a company in western europe i think it
was german or swiss swiss
uh which for years sold some of the best
encryption equipment in the world and it
turned out that it was totally
compromised and the cia had had a
backdoor into the technology for years
so people like me assume as a matter of
course that our
communications are compromised i i've
learned from
[Music]
people in the intelligence services
about ways to communicate very safely
i mean a few tips if you're not using a
vpn you're insane
and you should use that vpn in
conjunction with
good quality encryption technology
[Music]
i also use
message boards online
in the dark web to communicate with some
of my better sources
but have i had warnings from government
um
uh
no in fact i've had encouragement i've
had encouragement from people in
both australia's intelligence services
and enormous encouragement from
people in america
because i think frankly uh what's my
best interpretation of why this has been
kept a secret because it has there's
been a cover-up for years let's be
honest about this i don't know exactly
what they're covering up but they've
been covering stuff up for years
why have they covered it up
i actually suspect it's as simple as
the majority of people who are aware of
the phenomenon inside certainly the five
eyes that's australia new zealand
canada
the uk and the us
the majority of people who are aware of
the phenomenon inside the five eyes
aren't briefed into the ultra secret
material
so to them it's a genuine mystery
and the people that i've spoken to in
the main
in the main the people that i've spoken
to at least at the very beginning of my
research
were people who were prepared to
privately acknowledge to me that yes the
phenomenon is real
but with bugatti if we can understand
what it is
and uh
you know
i've spoken to people for example in our
intelligence and defense here in
australia who've told me that
you know there are objects mainly orbs
but but also craft routinely seen around
some of our more sensitive defense
installations particularly pine gap
which is the really super secret base in
the middle of australia that we run
jointly with america
and
they've said to me
that frankly their view is the reason
it's not talked about is because
governments are kind of embarrassed
about admitting it
that that
you know we're spending billions of
dollars a year for national defense and
the protection of our population i think
america has spent over a trillion
dollars since 9 11.
and to what effect if there is this
technology this intelligent technology
operating in our
skies our oceans and our atmosphere as
and our orbit um to what effect is this
money being expended if frankly
governments can't protect the public
against whatever it is or at least
inform the public of whatever it is
so i guess i'm giving you a very
long-winded answer but i want to give
you a a kind of a cultural understanding
of where i sit i think most people that
i've spoken to in defense of
intelligence in agencies that should
know
privately admit to me that they are as
confounded by the mystery as you and i
are
but i have also spoken to people who
privately admit that they know more and
that the us knows a great deal more but
that the united states has a very close
hold on that information
and it's it's more than top secret sci
this is something that is very very
closely guarded
and that the number of people that are
actually briefed into it inside the
military defense intelligence
infrastructure in the united states is
actually very few
it doesn't include presidents and it
doesn't include congress which i find
breathtaking
um so
yeah i mean i hope that answers your
question
sure you also mentioned you were
encouraged by some of the people in the
government
now when i was speaking to jim i'm not
sure if you saw this but i was speaking
with brian keating and tom delong and
jim semivan
i'll link that in the description and in
that conversation jim said when i asked
him how do you distinguish between
psyops or disinformation campaigns and
so on he said that the cia doesn't
conduct disinformation campaigns anymore
it's illegal right
[ __ ]
that's just such a i mean i've no
disrespect to tom i mean
i'm sorry i'm a keen student of cia mi6
sis and australian disinformation over
the years and one of the things you have
to be wise to as a journalist that
covers intelligence matters is
disinformation is part and parcel with
great respect of how organizations like
the cia operate
and for heaven's sake we need them i
mean we need disinformation
um
i mean the sad fact is that the cia was
a victim of disinformation going into
the iraq war i mean one of the biggest
catastrophes in recent time
was the disinformation that was spun by
ahmed chalabi and the iraqi national
congress to entice america into an
invasion of iraq on the false premise
that there were weapons of mass
destruction
and the
the thing that i don't think has been
adequately explored around the world is
the fact that america itself and britain
and australia were all victims of one of
the most clever disinformation
operations in recent time
so the notion that intelligence services
don't and aren't still using
disinformation to me is incredibly naive
disinformation is how intelligence
operates
and one of the things i'm wise to as a
journalist is
this is why i you know i've had people
tell me for example that there are
craft
non-human technology sitting in
warehouses somewhere in america
now
a lot of people in ufology when i say
that they think i'm saying yeah that's
real i believe it's real i don't
i can't nobody should
nobody should believe any of this until
they've seen it with their own eyes and
until we've actually literally kicked
the tyres of the tr-3b if it does have
tyres
but frankly we we have to be skeptical
because one of the plausible
explanations for me in my mind about why
america might be talking about this
stuff now is because it's worried about
a confrontation with china and maybe
it's trying to send a message to china
that it has some ace in the whole
technology perhaps derived from alien
technology that it's it's capable of
using and pulling out of the barrel if
it needs to in a confrontation
and uh you know frankly people have told
me that is the case but i'm not going to
believe it until i see it because
disinformation is so
so wild uh in intelligence uh you know
i i've been liked to so many times by
spies
and as journalists you just you just
have to
walk away because the first thing
they're wanting you to do is get really
excited and go oh wow you know i've been
told this by a real spy and i can
remember very early on in my career when
i did meet my first people who were
working in intelligence i was actually
based in southeast asia and
i met a cia station chief in a certain
asian country
and i was flattered to be a young
freelance journalist and being taken out
for a lunch in a restaurant i couldn't
afford by a guy who i knew was agency
and then i realized because i'd been in
possession of
information the week before i was being
lied to
and he wanted me to push a particular
line to support
a particular opposition group in a
particular company country
and realized that in the moment while
you were speaking with them i did and i
realized i was being manipulated and and
that this is something we all have to be
wise to in ufology i mean it may very
well still be and i really hope this is
the case if this is true
it may very well still be that america
really does have anti-gravity technology
you know maybe they've developed this on
their own and maybe it's got nothing at
all to do with aliens and maybe there's
been a clever disinformation program
uh to try and spread the uh
the uh
the notion around the world that america
is invincible because uh
it's somehow got alien technology
i mean i i just don't know
but i think we should really keep an
open mind i mean i i
i was amused i got a uh a bollocksing
from some
dweeb
debunker the other day who said i
believe in aliens and i believe in ufos
i don't necessarily what i'm doing is
i'm exploring the mystery which is what
journalists should be doing and there's
a fundamental misunderstanding here i
think this is one of the things that has
scared journalists off
because
there's a tendency i think for people to
assume that
uh
because i'm engaging with the subject
matter and taking it seriously and i do
think it should be taken seriously that
i believe credulously everything that
everybody says
i'm sorry but i i don't and i don't
think we should
do you think part of the reason for this
ridicule this jiving from large media
organizations against publishing
anything related to ufos is
related to chomsky's manufacturing
consent there's this relationship
between the media and the government a
symbiotic or you can see it as parasitic
look i've been in
on completely unrelated issues i've been
in editor's offices
in news media organizations when i'm in
possession of highly sensitive
information i i once did a story
for
one of australia's top public affairs
programs called four corners on the
public broadcast at the abc and
by complete chance there was a lot of
unhappiness inside our equivalent of the
cia asus the australian secret
intelligence service
and a number of
yeah and a number of australian spies
went public with me on national
television and one of the things they
talked about was
favors that we would do plausibly but
deniable favors that we would do for
either the brits or the americans which
gave the brits
plausible deniability or the americans
plausible liability
in the event that anyone got caught
or in the event that the operation
became public
and a lot of this involved bugging of
warsaw pact embassies during the cold
war you know if if you wanted a bug
planted in the uh embassy of the polish
republic
uh you know during the cold war you got
the aussies or the kiwis to do it or the
canadians funnily enough your crc was
very involved
and so the the junior cousins in the
five eyes alliance were basically used
as um
stooges to to go around doing plausibly
deniable favors and i can remember
when we
did that story we actually edited it
off-site because we were aware that
there were people inside the public
broadcaster who probably did report back
to the security services what was coming
up on programs like ours so we kept it
off the books and we kept it super super
confidential
and then in the wake of the program one
of the things that we revealed for
example was that um and i still to this
day i find it amazing because
we were sending our tech ops boys guys
who bugged rooms with highly
sophisticated bugs
to kuwait at the end of the 1991 gulf
war
to bug
kuwaiti government offices so that
british government
companies could win contracts in kuwait
against australian companies
and so these spies were saying to me why
are we doing this you know we're being
paid money by
britain to bug kuwait government
officers without the knowledge of
australian spy masters and these
plausibly deniable favors are being done
in such a way that they're actually
competing against australian companies
for the same contracts that are being
awarded
and another thing that was happening was
that in the period prior to the handover
in hong kong
you know incredibly sensitive
negotiations were going on between the
british held hong kong and the chinese
government and there were chinese
government offices in hong kong
and the the british wanted to know what
the chinese negotiating position was and
so
they planted bugs in the chinese
government's offices in hong kong
and the people who did that were
australians and we revealed that on this
program
and i can remember oh my god the
pressure we came under uh as a tv
network especially because we were a
government-owned broadcaster
i thought for a while i was going to go
to jail because um you know you know we
were revealing national secrets and we'd
essentially encouraged people who were
under a security oath to reveal what
they knew
and the the nice thing about it was
i'm sure they'd still dispute this to
this day but there were reforms made in
the accountability procedures of the
intelligence services to improve
themselves as a result of what we
revealed and it was a good healthy purge
frankly
but what it taught me was the
level of undisclosed communication that
occurs between government and a news
organization even a public broadcaster
like the abc in australia or your cbc in
canada
there are informal chats there are
informal relationships and
it's
i'm sure there is surveillance of
journalists in this country i've had
reason to believe over the years that
yes i am being tapped from time to time
i often do sensitive investigations that
upset governments and i guess i just
take it for granted that they're going
to monitor me uh and one of the things
that i'm agonized about is making sure i
protect sources this is one of the big
problems for me when i was writing my my
book
you know you you agonize about making
sure that if you're going to approach
somebody and invite them to give
information
um you know you need to be able to
protect them you have an ethical
responsibility to protect them
and
i've worked out ways of doing this in
the course of my research for the book
that
i hope have protected the
confidentiality of some of my more
sensitive sources
but
yes
uh there is
a nexus between media organizations and
government
when it comes to intelligence related
matters
that makes it very very difficult for me
to say that we are absolutely free
and i've seen compromises made inside
organizations when we've got
big stories which i find
kind of puzzling and irrational and it
wreaks to me that somebody's ahead of me
i had an incident once where i was
investigating um
uh
what are called disruption operations
there were refugees coming on boats from
indonesia across to australia and i
stumbled by complete chance across a
people-smuggling disruption operation
being run by
i thought
federal police
and it was done in conjunction with
members of our defence forces
and it was only belatedly that i
discovered that it was being done
also in conjunction with our isis uh
secret intelligence service and you know
there was some pretty pretty grubby
things being done to stop boats from
getting to australia
to disrupt people smuggling operations
and that's the scariest i've ever been
in my career
when i think one morning i came into my
office early and
i turned on my computer it had just been
in sleep mode and i suddenly realized
that the cursor on my screen
was moving through files
and i wasn't touching it
and
more importantly whoever the person was
when i did take control of the cursor
in the two or three minutes before they
realized that they'd been compromised
i realized that whoever they were had
super user status they were logged into
my system as a super user
and i could get into anywhere on the
network into places that i couldn't
normally get into
and i still remember i rang the it
department and i said
um
guys are you in my computer and they go
no and i said
i've got this weird thing where the
curse is moving on its own accord and
they told me to check your mouse you
know all these silly things turn your
computer on again and off again
and then um
and then i said yeah but i can get into
x-file
and i didn't say i'm not saying here
what that file was but suffice to say
the network at the time that i
the network that i worked for at the
time was owned by a billionaire called
kerry packer and i realized that not
only did i get into all of the files in
the news network i could also get into
all of the files in his business network
and i remember i sent this to the it guy
and i could hear him running down the
corridor towards my office and then both
of us watched as
this cursor moved across my screen
and then eventually just disappeared
and so somebody was on my computer and
it's the one time i've been aware as a
journalist that somebody was actually
accessing my material and i can tell you
i was scared it was a really scary time
because um
you know you realize that when the
forces of the state are deployed
on intelligence matters there's a degree
of ruthlessness and a degree of
willingness to break laws
to act unethically and improperly
because they are sanctioned to break
laws intelligence services are allowed
to do things that other sections of the
government aren't allowed to do
and um
it scared me it scared me as a
journalist and for a while there you
know i stayed away from the whole
subject matter because it was quite
intimidating the funny thing is that
with the phenomenon with ufos uaps
when i've
engaged with people at a senior level in
government and after
a fair
period of chatting about other things i
introduced the subject of uaps
there's two things i expect the first is
ridicule no laughter
and the second is a complete reluctance
to engage
and you know what neither has happened
i've been quite surprised i've spoken to
ministers and former ministers in our
government
i've spoken to people in our
intelligence and defence services
and when i raised the subject of
anomalous phenomena
they're immediately engaged
and it might be
exactly and it made me realize as a
journalist how badly we've dropped the
ball on this because
there was
talking about disinformation there was a
very deliberate disinformation program
instituted by
particularly the cia in the 1960s and
the 1970s
and for all i know it might have been
for quite laudable reasons because
apparently um
especially during project blue book they
were just getting swamped all of the
different agencies that were responsible
for monitoring foreign
incursions into america were getting
swamped with the sightings of anomalous
objects and and you can see in the
paperwork that there was a growing
concern that they weren't able to get on
top of
in the event of a a soviet attack they
wouldn't be able to get on top of
which warnings were legitimate which
warnings were just this weird anomalous
phenomena that nobody really wanted to
talk about
and uh
i can sort of understand why they wanted
to shut it down to me that's a semi
plausible reason and it's interesting
because when i've when i have
engaged with people about this in um
government
i've actually been very pleasantly
surprised and and it's why as a
journalist i feel motivated to continue
because
there is a
a willingness to accept that yes this is
a legitimate subject for investigation
and yes uh friends the americans are
probably hiding something from us we
accept that roscoe but that's pretty
pretty much parcel and parcel of the
five eyes yes we're cleared into the
intelligence that goes through the um
the sharing agreements under the five
eyes agreement but we're very very well
aware that the americans are always
working on things in private aerospace
and new defense technologies that we're
not always immediately read into and i
think a lot of them assume that the
objects that they're seeing are black
american technology
but they're definitely seeing things
what makes you think that your computer
is safe when you're using a vpn or on
the dark web if they can access your
computer and perhaps screen capture
even take keyboard logs
one of the things i regularly do and
i've been doing this for a while and
anybody can do this is
you can download some pretty good
virus trojan checking software from a
company called imazing
who
in particular they've been able to
detect the is it nro pegasus software
which is this really intrusive software
that's been used
very aggressively against journalists
including sadly the guy who was
chainsawed to pieces by the saudis in
turkey
you know there's been um
increasingly there's been misuse of
intelligence related technologies
particularly those built by the israelis
who are pretty ruthless in this regard
one of the things i've done a story
about you can actually i think you can
find this on the web
when i was at 60 minutes australia uh i
did a story that actually cbs 60 minutes
picked up as well on the
ss7 the signaling system 7
system that operates behind mobile phone
telephony
which essentially leaves a back door in
all mobile phones
these mobile phones that are so
ubiquitous that we use around the world
now without even thinking
they are wide open to tapping
wide open it's such a huge hole and it's
never been fixed because to fix it you
would actually need to change the whole
architecture of mobile phone
telephony and um i think it's really
important that people know this because
i assume as a matter of course
that all communications are compromised
um
uh
i
i use communication systems that
to a lot of people
would look insane
uh
to protect the security of some of my
more sensitive contacts
and that literally involves
both of us logging on with a vpn
and
tour
software
going into the dark web and accessing a
place in the dark where we essentially
leave messages for each other
that's about the only way a virtual dead
letter box that i can think of of coming
anywhere near
being able to uh protect the
confidentiality of a secure source
and i'll go to those steps i'll go to
those measures and i've warned i've done
speeches where i've talked about how
wide open mobile phone telephony is and
i see
i was shortly before the lockdown was
instituted here in australia i had lunch
with a federal minister in our
government who's in a very sensitive
portfolio
and he he was taking phone calls from
his staff on his normal mobile and i
said don't you have an encrypted phone
and he went rf effing [ __ ] you know
he says bloody things let just slow
things down and you can't hear you know
and i said yep you realize how wide open
these phones are and you went yeah yeah
that's what asd tells me all the time
and asd is the australian signals
director they're the people that
they do the bugging with the national
security agency as part of the five eyes
but they are also responsible for
communications
infrastructure security in this country
and um
you know i know that ministers are
warned all the time not to use mobile
phones but what they don't realize and i
i emulated this in a program where i was
in london
and a bunch of hackers in germany all
i'd done was give them my mobile
and i was in london and i said i'm going
to be having a phone call with a federal
politician in canberra in australia at 7
pm london time
can you hack me
and these german hackers from the chaos
computer club
working with a german company that
with legal authorization from the german
government we're using a ss7 portal
which is a portal that opens on the
internet to give you access to mobile
phone telephony they were able to hack
my phone call
by only knowing my phone number
because once they had my phone number
they were able to get my ime code once
they had my ime code they were then able
to patch into my phone call
using this
signaling system 7 backdoor messaging
channel that's used for mobile phone
telephony
and i really think this is important and
i'm sorry if i'm sounding like a nerd
for a moment but if anybody wants to see
my story about this i'm pretty sure it's
on the web just google ross cool mobile
phone telephony 60 minutes australia
it is an absolute outrage that the
communications companies haven't patched
up these holes and i always laugh when
you read apple giving assurances that
their phones have been made so more
secure or
where you read people from different
encryption companies talking about how
safe their phones are because they've
got encryption and you know
various levels of
245-bit encryption or whatever
the reality is that if you have the back
door that exists in mobile phone
telephony mobile phones are
wide open all governments know this and
all spy organizations know this and a
lot of private corporations that sell
data know this
and one of the things i did as part of
my research was i i
approached
companies in the us that freely sell
this technology they offer it for a lot
of money to anybody prepared to pay
and you can literally listen in i could
if i wanted to listen to all of your
phone calls kurt and i had the money i
could do it tomorrow
and it doesn't matter what you put on
your phone
and so people have got to stop thinking
that communications are in any way safe
and i say this to journalists all the
time i occasionally teach at journalism
schools and
i say to students you know you guys
really need to understand the importance
of protecting sources
and there's always a kind of a
nervousness about it because for
millennials this is how they communicate
this is how they engage this is how they
engage with culture
and what we don't realize is
how much we've given away as a result of
having this easy communication access
and what it's doing to investigative
journalism because
i assume as a matter of course that if
i'm communicating on a mobile phone
any communication is being monitored and
listened to
does that apply to if you're browsing or
if you're going on youtube or messaging
over a certain app
or is it only when you call someone
uh it's if you're using your mobile
phone either on the web or as a
communication tool they can they can
track you
there's no problem it's very very easy
to get hold of anything any data any
voice message any data any anything
that's going over your phone if you're
using your phone
when it comes to say using your pc or
your apple laptop to
browse the internet i mean sure you
should use a vpn and i use tor a lot for
confidential communications with sources
and for searches where i don't want
people to know what i'm searching
there's a great search engine called
duckduckgo which is an anonymized search
engine
but even then you should be using that
in conjunction with tor
and you should be updating the latest
versions of tor
[Laughter]
i'm i'm also
i used for years i think called pgp
pretty good privacy which was an
encrypted
uh system and if people look they'll
find there are very similar systems like
that there are that are commercially
available and
again because of crypto ag which i told
you about earlier i assume that all of
these have got backdoors in them and the
determined state
aggressor can access any communications
it wants to
i mean there are trojans that can be
inserted on any mobile phone
simply by you receiving that trojan you
don't even have to click on it
so
frankly
you know if somebody wants to hack you
they can hack you
but
am i really that important
by the way someone said that you may be
one of the most important people in the
world because of breaking this ufo case
oh thanks very much
this comes from the journalist david
bates who can be
followed at david b writer he wants to
know
given that you've published in a variety
of outlets
is there a particular do you work
on ufo stories for a particular outlet
that you know will back him up that's
sorry that he that you know will back
you up or do you have to pitch it to an
editor i guess what i'd really like to
know is is it possible that ross's work
may appear in the new york times and may
even collaborate with leslie keane
i work as a freelance journalist until a
few years ago i was working as an
investigative reporter for australia's
60 minutes program
but i have to be honest their commitment
to investigative journal journalism
diminished and
we just
they just weren't interested in what i
like doing anymore and quite frankly a
lot of media organizations aren't and
the only solution to that is to become a
freelancer and do it yourself
and i've been really happily surprised
because there are other organizations
that do want my content and i've
freelanced i've sold articles all around
the world i've made tv documentaries um
both here in australia and overseas i'm
an independent producer
i'm pitching documentary series and
dramatization series at the moment
and yes i have written in the past for
the new york times i've written for a
lot of the world's top newspapers over
the years
and i make documentaries and as people
would know if you go to the channel 7
australia spotlight program if you just
go into youtube and put in 7 channel 7
spotlight ufo
you'll be able to access for free the on
youtube the program that i made called
the ufo phenomenon
and i think in its current iteration
it's got about two and a half million to
three million views alone and that's the
second or third time we've put it up on
youtube so
i think we're now five or six million
views which is just mind-boggling and so
yeah i i'm finding that
it's quite funny
in the past i've had media organizations
that are quite reluctant to engage with
the subject of ufos because they're
worried about
stigma or ridicule
but the lesson from the ufo phenomenon
which i published in late
late may i think it was god time blight
but the the lesson from that film is
the audience know what the audience
wants i i've heard i have just been
overwhelmed
in the last few months i'm physically
and mentally exhausted at the moment
from the scale of response that i've had
to
both my book and also to the film
and it's very gratifying i mean the one
thing a journalist loves more than
anything else is knowing that his
audience are actually engaging with and
taking an interest in
the journalism that you make
and
that's certainly the case with with
subject matter like uaps ufos
and i find it very gratifying but also
the media organization that i have the
closest relationship at the moment which
is a huge commercial network called
channel 7 australia i work for them as a
contributor as a contributing freelancer
they are desperate for me to do more ufo
stories because wow
you know they've discovered that the
public are really interested in this
subject matter and and i was saying to
them i can remember uh i went for lunch
with a couple of the guys behind the
program late last year and i said oh
look i've got this um
i've got this documentary that i want to
do about ufos
and i sort of waited for them to giggle
nervously and um
instead they went absolutely we really
wanted
because they're getting the same level
of response you know they've never had a
response like this to a story before i
mean a tv network in australia does not
get five or six million views on youtube
for a story
and the reason why
they're getting this response is because
i you know i'm i'm fulfilling a need
people are interested in the subject
matter and i hope i i pray that i'm
engaging with it in an objective and
fair
and impartial way and using the skill
set that i would normally use as an
investigative journalist to analyze
anything
and i think that's what people are
responding to that um
no disrespect to any of my peers one of
the problems i have with ufology is i
think there's far too much of glib
acceptance of assertions you know we
people want it even though they they
want to believe
i'm not into belief when people ask me
do i believe in ufos i say look i just
don't know i really don't know
what i do know
are certain things
there is
there is an anomalous phenomenon that is
clearly engaging with humanity
i don't care what the debunkers or the
skeptics say when i had my meetings with
different people from different
three-letter agencies in the u.s
and conversations with people in your
country
australia new zealand and britain and
france it became immediately clear to me
that the military and intelligence
services of all of our countries are
very aware of the reality of the
phenomenon and they are not able to
offer prosaic explanations for that
phenomenon
and to use lou's observables they are
they're doing hypersonic maneuvers tens
of thousands of kilometers an hour
they're real solid objects lou uses the
term i noticed craft vehicle more often
he started out saying objects but
increasingly have you noticed he's he
started using the word craft or vehicle
they are clearly intelligently
controlled they're responding in an
intelligent way
and so if you go through all of those
observables and when i've run them i've
you know i've run them past they're very
useful because i've run them past
different officials in different
countries and they all agree you know
they can't explain this
and so that's what i come back to
what i do know you know and if people
ask me what i believe i go it's not
relevant
what i know
is
what can be verified
and and we are now at a situation which
i find quite astonishing
where the most powerful country on the
planet
america has formally admitted the
phenomenon is real
that's huge that's a major step forward
but are they going to be more
forthcoming i somehow doubt it
are you able to keep up with responding
to people who email you compliments like
you perhaps get 100 a day or 200 even
i had i had 167 new emails this morning
and uh i was going through them before i
logged in to talk to you
there's no way i can get on top of them
at the speed that people want i've i've
had a few people i've had a few people
angrily demanding to know why i haven't
responded back to them yet and they've
sent me like a hundred pages of data and
i i go look you know i'll get to it when
i've got my time you know i'm not funded
by a major media organization to do this
investigative research i just do it
and
even if you were funded you only have a
certain amount of time the time is the
main issue
well this is the big thing i mean this
is the compromise that you often make in
commercial and indeed in public
broadcasting television with
investigative journalism because sooner
or later if you've spent two or three
weeks on a story
the boss comes up to you and he goes hey
roscoe mate
uh time's getting on you know yeah it's
the story when's the story coming up
we've got a holder filled and so for me
the enormous freedom that i have at the
moment i've i've moved to the country
i've um
i've got the ability as a freelancer to
take my time to do things i'm a bit
older than most i'm 59 soon to turn 60
and uh i you know i've i've
i've had a lot of the fun in my
journalistic career
before now
but i i've devoted
a chunk of my time to investigating the
phenomenon because
one thing as a journalist that you
develop
is a nose for a good story
believe me this is a good story it's a
great yarn
and
i'm kind of hoping frankly that my
friends in
other media organizations don't jump on
the bandwagon because
once the
cbs's abc's and nbc's of this world
actually start deploying their
investigative teams and spending serious
coin not investigating the phenomenon
i'm going to be left for dust you know i
mean
really we are i think you know as a
media person i can tell you i think
we're on the cusp of
an adjustment in the media you've still
got those outliers who go oh it's all
[ __ ] you know it's all rubbish you
know ridicule ridicule stigma stigma
taboo
and you know and i've had a few of them
ring me because i'm i'm part of a group
called icij the
international consortium of
investigative journalists based out of
washington dc and a lot of us talk to
each other on the web and share ideas
and stories and a few of them have
become aware that i've written a book on
ufos and i was in a spanish newspaper uh
a few days ago and um
one of my spanish journalist friends
rang me and
he went oh russ you're doing a book on
ufos and i went yeah it's already
published and he went oh really and then
he rang me back about two days later and
he read my book and he watched my
documentary and i waited for him to read
it i waited for him to ridicule me and
uh because normally that's what happens
normally somebody takes the piss and
says oh mate you've gone crazy you know
you've got tin foil hat on your head you
know
and the hilarious thing was he started
talking to me about ufo sightings he was
aware of as a very senior spanish
journalist that he'd never reported
about you know and he'd had sources from
the government and the defense and
intelligence services in his country
talked to him about it
and i said to him i said why why did he
never publish the stories and he went
look to be honest ross it's you know
there is so much taboo you know people
do not go near the subject because it is
people laugh at you and i would
well not a lot of people are laughing at
me i said the only people that are
laughing at me are sort of desperate
outliers who frankly i don't care too
much about and i said frankly mate i
don't want to encourage you to go into
the subject matter because it's such a
good story for me right now you know
it's fertile pasture
and he he promised to go away and renew
his contacts with his sources and go
back and start looking at the subject
matter and i think that's going to
happen i think there's a cultural change
happening here and the media normally
take about a year or two to catch up
with what's really happening and i think
what we're going to see eventually is an
adjustment the media will start engaging
with
uaps as a legitimate subject matter for
investigation
man there's so much like i got to get to
some audience questions but i want to
riff on that even for me with this show
with this podcast some of the most
successful episodes are the ones where i
investigate this uap phenomenon and i do
it
like a fledgling i barely know much
about the subject at all and i also see
that there's this twin phenomenon of
extreme disparagement mainly on the
but on the part of a
it's not necessarily public let's say
media and then there's
extreme acceptance in some of the ufo
community
and
perhaps because i'm neither
there's there's some interest okay i i
can tell you there is a wisdom of the
crowd do you know that term a wisdom of
the crowd with the phenomenon
uh
i am struck by an effect i mean i've i'm
doing some renovations from my house at
the moment and
a couple of workmen have come by in
recent weeks and now i'm reasonably well
known in this country and they've seen
my documentary and it's interesting
because
they've all got ufo stories and they all
want to talk about it and
it's just one of those things that i
think our society has
for no good reason
suppressed as a legitimate issue for
serious discussion and investigation
and uh what i'm struck by i mean we're
not allowed to go to dinner parties at
the moment in australia because we're
basically operating under authoritarian
lockdown rule it's outrageous i can't
believe how meek supposedly
anti-authoritarian australians are being
because we've basically all been locked
up in our homes for the last few months
but
in the period before that when i went to
dinner parties or social events and told
people i was working on a book about
ufos
people were really interested
and there's an instant click where
people go yes
yes this is i really want to hear more
about this and um you know my wife god
bless her she got quite annoyed because
we'd go to parties and i would just be
cornered by people and all they wanted
to do was talk about ufos
and uh it's interesting because
i uh i went to a conference in canberra
which is our capital city in australia
uh and it was a conference that was
attended by a number of defense and
intelligence officials and
i was just in a corner talking to an
admiral in our navy and um
uh
this other bloke walked up i won't say
who he was but he was from a certain
agency and
and he said oh
oh are you talking to ross about ufos
and uh and i went no no no talking we're
talking about the submarines and um
and uh it was very funny because then
the guy i was talking to you went oh
forget submarines what are you talking
about ufos are you writing a book on
ufos and then immediately uh you know
this guy starts talking to me about um
he was a submariner and uh he was
talking to me about how
australian submarines regularly
encountered what he called usos uh
underwater submerged objects
and so this whole conversation took off
where i found myself in a corner in a
conference with these uniformed
officials who were all like little
school boys guests backing away to me
about um the phenomenon that they'd
witnessed during their
younger careers and how puzzled and
mystified they were by it
and uh i ventured to suggest i remember
one of them i said look do you think the
americans know a lot more than the
they're letting on and he just tipped
his head back and went oh of course they
do
of course they do
and um you know and as events
subsequently showed when i went to the
united states and sat down with people
in washington and um
parts of california uh that proved to be
the case
all right william e has a question
what's your take on corso's book the day
after roswell
look i
i don't know i mean i think there's a
lot about the corso book that that makes
sense
i do think roswell was a cover-up i find
it quite laughable it's actually quite
hilarious seeing the double black flip
with pikes that the us air force has
committed in order to try and
perpetrate the lie and continue the lie
that it's been telling
i just honked with laughter because
there's a great article i quoted chunks
of it in my book from maureen dowd in
the new york times
when uh back in
oh god 1995 i think it was the us
government put out its latest lame
excuse for what roswell was
and they claimed that yes humanoid
objects creatures were seen but um they
were test dummies that were dropped from
a balloon at 80 000 feet
and then maureen died just laughed and
went oh my god if anything's convinced
me more than ever that the united states
government is hiding something about
roswell it's this really lame
explanation
i mean
i don't know what they're hiding about
roswell i mean i've spoken to people in
the u.s government who told me that
roswell was a craft and that it was
crashed and it was retrieved and that it
was a crash between two craft
and they uh interesting both both of
them crashed and they were retrieved and
taken to wright-patterson air force base
but you know
do i believe that no not really not
until i've
got further evidence to substantiate it
in my mind i mean and so when i read
things like the corso book
i i've looked into the history of
corso i mean he's
he was quite amazing i mean he was a
really interesting figure because he
you know he was no lightweight and and
when you look at his service history and
the people that he was connected with
it's quite something that he came out
and said what he said because he really
effectively destroyed his relationships
with people in the military and
intelligence establishment by taking the
stand that he took
and
he wasn't mad he wasn't nuts
and a lot of a lot of what he said has
been independently verified and
validated so yeah i mean i
i don't know
whether it's all true i mean i i
certainly don't buy the explanation that
all of the technology such as microchips
and integrated circuits were created as
a result of recoveries from alien
spacecraft i think that's nonsense
but i am persuaded by the fact that the
guy that co-wrote the book with corso
uh extrapolated from things that corso
had told him and misrepresented what
corso was actually saying
because i've i've read
earlier versions of what corso said and
he didn't say what is attributed to him
to the extent that is is written in that
book
uh i mean i think one of the most
damaging criticisms of corso is that he
falsely claimed that
all of the great breakthroughs and
stealth technology and integrated
circuits and even velcro and things like
that were as a result of what was found
on an alien spacecraft
and when you actually go back and look
as i have done at what he actually said
and then look at what was ended up put
it being put in the book
they're two different things
i would have loved to have met him i've
spoken to people who knew him well and
they've explained very much what i've
just explained to you as well and they
think he should be taken seriously
and i am
sure
that
he was
in possession of material
that came from the foreign technology
division and that he was farming
some of it up to
private aerospace and private technology
what i'm not sure about are some of the
more wild claims that have been made on
his behalf
and this is one of the things you have
to watch out for because
um
[Music]
i'm aware of
instances where people make claims
and then all of a sudden they become
associated with a claim that frankly is
demonstrably untrue
and i do think there is active
disinformation going on at the moment
even now from forces in
american intelligence who
they're not trying to suppress so much
as they used to they're just trying to
control because what's happening at the
moment i think is a decision has been
made inside the u.s government that yes
we're now at a stage where we have to
admit that there is a real phenomenon we
have to admit that there is an anomalous
phenomena that is
real you know we can't deny it anymore
the too many sensor systems too many
phased array radar systems are now
installed on different aircraft too many
high quality video systems too many
data points are picking it up we can't
deny it but what we want to do i think
there's been an active decision made to
constrain the
current uap task force's investigations
from
2004.
i don't think they want us to know
anything about
alleged crash recoveries or
any of the other more extraordinary
claims that have been made over the
years by people like corso it's almost
like what they're trying to do is
present
a scenario to the
american and international public
where the american government can in a
few years time go
guys
look what we've discovered this is
amazing um there really is a real
phenomenon and look we're part way there
because they've acknowledged the
phenomenon is real but i suspect we'll
be told that
you know there is perhaps some
intelligence that we don't yet
comprehend that is operating in our
on our planet i i do i really do suspect
that and i've been led to that belief by
people who know
but i do believe that hopes that we're
going to see disclosure of the truth
behind crash recoveries the truth behind
alleged alien retrievals the truth
behind mutilations and
my labs and abductions i don't think
we'll ever see that
and i think what's happening at the
moment is there is a desperate i do
believe by the way that the united
states has recovered what it believes is
non-human technology
there upset it yeah i think i think i
think the level of proof is sufficient
in my mind to assert that there is
non-human technology in the hands of the
us government
but i don't think it wants anybody to
know that and i think what it's trying
to do at the moment is control the
narrative
and
i think there's a degree of nervousness
about
letting the uap task force run
because i do think
the people in tom delong's to the stars
academy we're getting close to
highly classified secure special access
programs that are kept completely off
the books inside the us government that
aren't part of the normal disclosure
process before congress even before the
gang of eight you know waived
unacknowledged special access programs
it's way beyond that
and i do believe that the us is sitting
on technology that it's trying to
suppress its knowledge of its existence
and i don't know how they're going to
get away with that and
it worries me because
it raises accountability issues
you know why hasn't the congress been
enformed why have presidents been kept
in the dark
[Music]
what have presidents been told
you know for example it's quite obvious
to me if you look
between the lines of what both obama
trump
clinton
[Music]
jimmy carter have all said it's quite
obvious that presidents have been
briefed in to some degree
but what have they been told you know
uh is there a group of generals and
intelligence people inside the uh
the pentagon and the cia who are trying
to control the narrative i i suspect
there is and i think there's a battle
going on inside
different intelligence agencies in the
us
to try and
one one group is more open and
transparent and thinking that their duty
banned under the constitution to be more
open and obliging to reveal what they
know because there's no good reason not
to reveal it but there's another group
that probably also because of religious
ardent zealotry uh reluctant to see the
full story told i think for a lot of
people who are of extreme religious
faith and that's not to be in any way
critical of people who are believers
um i think a lot of people because i do
think you know i think the vatican for
example has made it quite clear that if
you are religious and if you believe in
ets we are they are all god's children
you know i don't think the idea of
alien life is incompatible and people
should take a closer look at what
religious institutions like the vatican
have actually said about this
but
i'm told and i've been told this by
multiple sources that there are people
of extreme conservative religious
viewpoints inside the cia
and also inside the defense intelligence
agency and other agencies who are
hostile to
revealing the extent of what the us
government knows
and i do know because they believe it's
connected to what's demonic
i think it's demonic they think it's
satanic
and who knows
i mean i'm not religious but it might be
maybe we're all going down a very
dangerous path
right
okay so this question comes from harry
white he wants to know if you've seen
any orbs or any ufo
phenomenon or
and or what is his opinion with the
summoners
i don't know what he means oh you mean
ce5 that sort of thing i'll assume
that's what he means okay um i i i
haven't had any direct experiences
myself with the phenomenon i wish i had
i'd love it if make your job easier
oh wouldn't it be fantastic i've
i i have been there's a guy called
damian not no double t here in australia
who's quite
astonishing with his ability to
know
when the phenomenon is about to manifest
itself and i remember he was
i was sitting with him on a sofa in his
house in pennant hills in north eastern
sydney and northwestern sydney and
he just suddenly went up excuse me
grabbed a camera went outside
pointed it up in the air and
got
vision of an object moving erratically
across the sky and i said how did you
know that that was going to be there and
he went i i don't know i just don't know
but um i commend his work he he did an
excellent film called austra alien skies
alien as in a-l-i-e-n
um but um
he's just got the most extraordinary
collection of um
objects that he's seen and he does seem
to be able to mentally engage with the
phenomenon i mean and when when i've got
as i have done i've got people in
defense and intelligence in the us
telling me that whatever this phenomenon
is it engages
in a mental way in almost a telepathic
way with human beings
i don't know
you know the debunkers can scoff as much
as they like you know i i i mean when
people are telling me this
i i i can't dismiss it and more
importantly i've i've seen
people who purport to be able to do what
um
i think stephen greer calls uh ce5
and um
[Music]
you know
i can't dismiss
it speaking on the topic of
consciousness and ufos there aren't many
places with quality documentaries on the
subject if you're endeavoring to learn
more about those topics curiosity stream
access and ancilla to that quest
furnishing a variety of documentaries on
consciousness and ufos i recommend you
watch stephen hawking's favorite places
which combines quite a few of the
interests of this channel namely the
unification quest in physics alien life
and artificial intelligence go to
curiositystream.com
toe that is t-o-e for unlimited access
to some of the world's top documentaries
and non-fiction series use the promo
code t-o-e to get 25 off the annual
subscription that amounts to just about
fifteen dollars that's approximately one
dollar per month which trounces
virtually any of the other video
streaming services the link is below and
do let me know what you think of stephen
hawking's favorite places
okay this question comes from poop digg
what does he think i know
what does he think of admiral wilson i
mean why does he think admiral wilson
docks are legit and i believe you've
explained this in your in plain sight
but if you can give it to people yeah
actually actually if he reads my book he
would see that i can see at the end of
my analysis of the admiral wilson
documents that we cannot reach any
conclusion about them until and if
either tom wilson
or eric davis concedes that the
documents are a real account of a real
conversation
um i do believe
that there is a strong body of evidence
to suggest that the provenance of the
documents is very very solid and
i write about a guy to whom i give the
student in my book the space man
and
he was a very very close friend of edgar
mitchell
and it turned out when he got to know me
he confided that he was the custodian of
edgar mitchell's private ufo archives
and
he allowed me access to those archives
and in those archives is the original of
the admiral wilson document that was
leaked out onto the web in about 2018
and that was done by a good friend of
mine here in australia james
rigney who passed it on to grant cameron
and richard dolan
so
i'm very sure
of the provenance of the admiral wilson
document it came from edgar mitchell's
estate
and i'm also very sure that it was
written by dr eric davis a man for whom
i have an enormous amount of respect
um
and i'm pretty sure that the document
was faxed by dr hal put off to
edgar mitchell because edgar mitchell
was on the science advisory board for
the national institute of discovery
science which was the private
science investigative body that was
investigating the paranormal for bob
bigelow the aerospace and real estate
entrepreneur
and i've also done an analysis of the
comments made by all of the people
who are
parties if you like to the prominence of
the document
and
none of them you would think let me put
it this way
if you were eric davis
and people were circulating a document
that purports to be eric davis's notes
of his alleged conversation with admiral
tom wilson the immediate past director
of the defense intelligence agency
in a car park ironically the car park at
and g you couldn't get more spooky than
that you know the eg g company in las
vegas
and they're discussing
a covert
aerospace company's concealment on
behalf of certain elements of the us
government and intelligence
establishment
of
retrieved
alien technology and how it's been kept
secret from the
u s public for so many years
you would expect that such a wild wacky
conspiracy theory would be immediately
denied by
a man with a security oath to protect
and
you know a need to be seen to be a loyal
patriot of america you know you wouldn't
want false rumors to be being
disseminated on your name
but what has eric davis done if anything
in an interview with stephen greenstreet
on the basement which for some perverse
reason green street took down
eric davis
uh made a number of admissions that i
thought were quite pertinent to this and
i write about them in the book
um
tom wilson of course admiral tom wilson
in a letter to me has adamantly denied
that any such conversation took place
but on analysis at the end of all of it
whilst i say i cannot
rule out the possibility that the
document is real and that it records a
valid conversation and possibly real
events
because i can't get anybody on the
record to prove the document to to
establish that it is a genuine record of
essentially a truthful conversation and
that that truthful conversation records
actual facts actual reality not
disinformation
um i'm not prepared to assert that the
april tom wilson memo is for real
uh so contrary to what your interrogator
poses i'm not saying that i have
validated it to my satisfaction that it
records real events
what i have said is that there are
aspects of the
responses from the different parties
that don't make sense if that document
is a fake
because don't you think i mean this is a
guy eric davis works for aerospace
corporation and he's working on
apparently uh propulsion technologies
next generation propulsion technologies
there is no doubt in my mind he has to
have a top secret sci compartmentalized
security clearance in order to do that
so he has to be positive vetted to make
sure that he's a
a decent
man who's allowed to be given america's
most sensitive secrets
don't you think that if he was aware
that a memo was fake
he'd say so
and he's never done that
and that to me is the most conspicuous
part of the entire admiral wilson
document saga i know it's complex but it
really is worth people getting their
heads around and that's why i went to a
lot of trouble to write about it in my
book i wanted people to understand the
history of the document and how it was
that admiral wilson
allegedly came to make those inquiries
because all credit to
dr stephen greer interestingly he's long
mocked and ridiculed by a lot of people
in
ufo research
it was he who initiated with edgar
mitchell a meeting with admiral tom
wilson in 1997 that kicked the ball off
the ball off and tom admitted to me that
meeting took place
and there are five people um stephen
greer
edgar mitchell sherry adamiak commander
willard miller
and i think one other who were all
present and who heard allegedly tom
wilson making admissions about his
inability to get to the bottom of the
truth of the matter
about uaps
so you have to take into context the
assertions of all of these people as
direct witnesses with what is being said
by
a past director of the defense
intelligence agency
who makes it very very clear in the memo
in question that if it ever becomes
public he would have to lie about it
and nobody
is to say anything frankly in my view
that should detract from the fact that
admiral tom wilson is an honorable
decent
loyal
patriot
if i was in his position
that's exactly what i would do he's
bound by a security oath and frankly it
may very well be that there is some
solid national security reason that you
and i don't yet know that explains why
we're not allowed to know this stuff
that's one thing i've been really
struggling with and i just want to make
this point and frankly if there's
anybody out there from any of those
three letter agencies that's watching
this i'm wide open to this because this
has happened to me before
i once became aware of a military
deployment by australian forces overseas
and i was given a heads up that it was
happening
and
i queried the defense department about
it and
i was asked not to run it
and i didn't run it because there was no
good reason for me to jeopardize the
safety of australian troops being
deployed overseas
just for a story
and in this case i've asked people i've
said to people is there a legitimate
reason why we're not allowed to know
about what it is that the united states
government knows the extent of what it
knows about the phenomenon
and nobody that i've spoken to has been
able to give me a good answer
nobody's been able to give me any solid
national security reason in fact they've
suggested that it's just been kept
secret for no good reason it's just a
relic of the cold war and now there is a
small cluster of generals admirals and
spooks and politicians who are a bit
embarrassed that if it all does become
public they're going to have to admit
that they've lied for years to the
american public the parent presidents
have been deceived and there's probably
been criminal contempts of congress and
this is why there should be
hearings in congress
but
i can understand why it might be
necessary for some of those hearings to
be held in camera
because the people that
america trusts with its secrets the
congress the oversight bodies like the
senate intelligence committee or the
armed services committee they should at
least have an opportunity to say to
these people under oath
okay
we now know that there is a x
issue that you've never revealed to us
before about the uh the united states
knowing about uaps ufos
why haven't you told us about this
before what's that reason and under oath
in confidential hearing they should be
given an opportunity to explain that
and then frankly
if they can't explain it
then the public should be told
but oddly i as a journalist see i have a
responsibility because i often get told
things that i shouldn't
i have a responsibility to ensure that
i'm not jeopardizing public safety or
national security by inadvertently
revealing something i shouldn't
so i've been giving people that
opportunity along the way i've been
waiting for somebody to tell me hey
listen there's a really good reason for
this and
look i've had a number of explanations
that i'm not quite sure about yet but
none of which i'm ready to talk about
publicly but
i'm not satisfied that there is a good
reason and i want to hear it
so if there is one
tell me
can't they just say national security
and that's the reason why we didn't tell
anyone
are you gonna
are you gonna accept that kind of
[ __ ] excuse i'm not i mean i've been
told so many times that something's a
subject of national security and i mean
i remember look at the um
look at the warrantless wiretapping that
was going on under the under your
legislation under the u.s legislation
where the national security agency and
other government departments were
essentially illegally allowed to
warrantlessly wiretap
hundreds of millions of innocent
americans
in what was essentially an overreaction
to 911 and it was a fundamental breach
of the constitutional rights of freedoms
of
you know being allowed to have a private
conversation you know privacy is a right
and uh you know we
we can't just glibly accept assertions
of national security claims like that
need to be tested tyranny starts when
governments use secrets to conceal
mistakes and that's that's my worry here
my worry here is that the explanation
for
what has happened with the ufo
phenomenon is purely and simply that
years ago
some pompous general decided that it was
better to keep it confidential because
you know we know better than the rest of
you
and you know we want to try and
replicate this technology that's
assuming that we've recovered technology
and um
frankly even though there's no good
reason now for
not revealing it they've dug themselves
so deep into a lie for so long
they don't know how to get out of it
they're worried about being excoriated
and vilified in the court of public
opinion but they should be frankly if if
they've lied if they've mislead congress
i mean one of the things that frankly i
just don't get
and this is something i really don't
understand is if you read jacques
villa's forbidden knowledge volume four
it has the most extraordinary series of
exchanges between jacques vallee who's
one of the godfathers of ufo research
and a guy called richard dick demato who
was the staffer on the senate
intelligence committee in a role very
similar to the role that was played by
chris mellon years later
and dick tomato back in the 1970s was
talking to jacques valet
openly in private conversation
about how he was trying to get to the
bottom of the government cover-up about
ufos and i look i've approached dick
tomato and
he doesn't want to talk
and you know he's probably bound by a
security oath but he was making no
secret to jacques villa who
mischievously put this in his diaries
back in the 1970s that he knew
that as the person responsible as the
staff are responsible for probably the
most important intelligence oversight
body in the congress
he couldn't get access to information
that he knew existed
and
this is what worries me what worries me
is that this may be a crisis of
accountability
if the wilson memo for example is a
truthful and accurate document
what it means is
essentially
technology that is rightfully the
possession and
you know the property of the american
people if not the human race
is being divested into the private
ownership of a private aerospace company
and oversighted only by a very few
people
in government
who are terrified of the secret getting
out
and
their efforts to back engineer this
technology
allegedly because of the incredible
secrecy attached to the whole program
have been hindered because of their
inability as scientists to be able to
share data and discuss what what they're
looking at with other scientists
imagine if
hypothetically the united states is in
possession of retrieved technology
imagine hypothetically
if the united states is sitting on an
alien spacecraft or multiple spacecraft
imagine if that was the case
imagine if
they've failed in 76 years
to back engineer arbi to back engineer
that
technology um
don't you think there comes a time when
they have to
truthfully engage with the american
public and say
we've lied to you
we're very sorry
and i this is why i've actually floated
in previous interviews the idea of a
truth and reconciliation commission as a
journalist i covered the south african
truth and reconciliation commission
where in quite a beautiful way the evils
of the apartheid regime under the
racist government of south africa
before it became independent under
nelson mandela
they were always covered up and then
they had a truth and reconciliation
regime where killers like the killers in
the
south african security service who'd
literally murdered people for the state
were allowed to truthfully sit in public
hearing
and tell their story knowing that they
were being given full immunity and full
indemnity and frankly i think that's
what we should offer to the people who
are hiding this secret because it's far
too important to have a purge to go
jumping on people and criticizing them
for not revealing it i suspect that
their motivations for hiding it in the
very beginning were quite honorable
we were in the cold war
and we found a life form to quote the
general
i mean i'm referring there to something
that tom delong gave in an interview
when he says he was told by a person he
referred to as the general
it was the cold war and every day we
lived in fear that you know the world
was about to fall apart
and then we found a life form you know
there was a different context during the
cold war that i think informed america's
national security imperatives i would
have kept the secret
but if it is the case if
it is the case that the united states
has recovered alien technology and i
don't know for sure that they have
i suspect they have
then
unless there's a good reason for
continuing to conceal it and i'd like to
hear that
i think we need to provide a means for
them to be exculpated
and to be honorably recognized for
bringing it out into the
american public's knowledge
because
let me just
be a whimsical person for a moment
discuss what i love about america
as a little boy i remember looking up at
the moon and thinking how incredible it
was that a country on my planet had put
men on the moon you know it was just
unimaginable to me as a little boy and i
had all my apollo moon mission models
and i was fascinated with the idea that
you know a nation had collaborated
scientifically
in such a short period of time
to do incredible things
you know what a monumental achievement
and that was an illustration to me of
what humanity can achieve and i'm really
struck i was only reading yesterday
about how
shortly before his death john f kennedy
in november the
1963
instructed his cia director to
begin
sharing
intelligence with the russians
and to look at a collaborative space
research program with the russians
and there was such promise there
internationally
about pulling ourselves out of the cold
war with adventurism
exploration
science research
new ideas
and if it is the case if it is the case
that the united states is sitting on
technology and i suspect it is
imagine what that technology could do
for humanity
and imagine how we're being held back
because of the
fear
the cowardly fear of a few men
in dark rooms
who are hiding these secrets
wouldn't it be a wonderful thing if we
could usher in a new age of propulsion
systems energy
advances in technology that the world
has never seen pull human beings out of
poverty
you know be fantastic
exploration understand our solar system
understand our universe
these things could be achieved if there
really is
faster than light travel or some kind of
anti-gravity technology or propulsion
system
and
the interesting thing
is
someone
something
out there
is flying
craft
that appear to have these technologies
and the world just goes on you know the
pentagon makes these admissions it
actually admits that it cannot
proximately explain this phenomenon
which is doing maneuvers and speeds far
beyond our technology
instantaneous velocity hypersonic
maneuvers
and we just get on with our lives and
politely ignore it like it's not
happening or worse still we give
currency to some stupid debunker who
comes up with some lame excuse that
frankly doesn't make sense
it's time for people to wake up to
themselves and realize that
the united states
i know for sure is sitting on secrets
that it is not yet revealing
and i don't know why it's not doing that
but i have in the course of my research
become privy to knowledge that
makes me realize that
they are concealing stuff
now if they're concealing technology
i think the public has a right to know
about it unless there's some solid
national security reason that can be
provided that explains why
so my only point is we need to provide a
means a system to facilitate them
feeling okay about doing that we need to
provide people with essentially an
indemnity against prosecution if they
speak outside the constraints of their
security oath
if they reveal crimes if crimes have
been committed
there has to be a full and open
accounting
and frankly you're not going to get that
in the congress
at the moment it's not going to happen i
don't care what
some of the more optimistic predictors
say
i don't think there is a mood in the
congress for any further disclosure i
think the uap task force will be created
into a permanent office
in all likelihood but it will be
woefully underfunded and like project
bluebook it'll eventually be dribbled
out of existence
and frankly the only way any impetus is
going to be developed on this is if the
public wakes up and realizes the awesome
significance of what the pentagon has
already admitted
okay this question comes from quantum
cryogenics do you agree with
eric davis that ufo experiences always
always come with poltergeist effects
i don't know i don't know enough about
it i i genuinely don't know enough about
um ufo experiences i have huge respect
for dr eric davis uh but um
i haven't witnessed what he's witnessed
i'm in no position to comment
all right then this one comes from dan
zetterstrom of the ufo podcast which i
saw you on i listened to those two parts
this is he says slide nine and i'll also
link the podcast in the description
slide nine specifies instantaneous
sensor disassembly
we've also seen human and cattle
referred to as biosensors when it comes
to the phenomenon the prospect for
disassembly of these things is startling
does that lead to cognitive manipulation
i think it does
what does he mean by cognitive
manipulation so explain this question to
me and then give that okay
okay
slide nine just to give you some context
uh
slide nine was part of a group of slides
from a powerpoint
display
that was certainly prepared and maybe
used in a briefing for the under
secretary of the department of defense
from people in the office of the under
secretary of defense intelligence
probably parts of the uap task force or
atip
the advanced aerospace threat
three-notation program and probably when
lua lozondo was in charge there
i don't know for sure i haven't asked
lou directly about it i should have done
but essentially slide nine is the ninth
slide in those power points that we used
for a briefing and
frankly if these were used in a briefing
they are absolutely astonishing because
the provenance of the document is really
not in doubt i've more than satisfied
myself as to the prominence of the
document
and slide 9 shows that the under
secretary for the department of defense
was being advised that the phenomenon is
capable of
psychotronic weaponry
and when you look up psychotronic which
i did i immediately googled it it's
essentially describing what the slide
goes on to describe which is the
capacity to manipulate human perception
and consciousness
and as dan has rightly pointed out
it also involves the capacity to
remotely
manipulate an instantaneous sense or
disassembly and what that's a reference
to is the meddling that has been going
on and is
still going on
with nuclear weapons
uh
uh i mean i've i'm very cautious to talk
about the stuff that i know that's
current because some of it is still
quite national security sensitive but
there is a genuine concern
inside the us
and also interestingly i noted in france
india
and russia
those are the countries that i've spoken
to
somebody is screwing with their nuclear
weapons
they're having instances where weapons
are going down and they just won't
function and they can't find anything
wrong with things
systems that are supposedly secure
it's almost as if whatever it is is
demonstrating to them how
insecure their systems are because if
you think about it
if something and this is irrefutable
something is demonstrating a capacity to
middle with the most dangerous weapons
on the planet
and people don't realize that the
bulletin of atomic scientists that has
this clock
showing the hands towards midnight
that hand
is closer to midnight
than at many other times in our history
right now
you know we may think that the threat of
nuclear war has diminished but there is
from all of the people that i'm talking
to at the moment
an ever-present fear that we are on the
brink of a confrontation with china
let's say it for what it is people are
talking about war with china it's scary
you know i'm really worried about it i'm
preoccupied with it frankly
australia has just recently bought or
agreed to buy nuclear submarines from
the brits and the americans
in an amazing new defense relationship
called walkers because we're so paranoid
about china
and it's like we're sleep walking into a
war and so
in that context when you think about how
close that clock is to midnight
you also need to be aware that something
is continuing to middle with our nuclear
weapons and these sightings are ongoing
these meddlings are ongoing there are
remote
meddlings or if you like one person i
spoke to said they were like
demonstrations something is
demonstrating a capacity to shut down
nuclear weapons or as has reportedly
happened in one case in the united the
ussr
a capacity to wind up nuclear weapons to
turn them there's only one case
ever in the whole world that you know
about the that's the one case i know
about directly uh where i've spoken to
russians who purport to have a direct
knowledge of it yes
but i wouldn't be surprised at all if
there were others
okay administrative fudge eight asks
does he have information on hayim ashed
former head of israeli defense ministry
i'm certain he briefly mentioned it when
talking in project unity in an interview
but i might be wrong that's what he said
yeah
when um
when i was writing my book uh
a lot of people would remember there was
this guy who was a former head of the
israeli
space program i don't even know the
israelis had a space program but he was
a former head of the israeli space
program
and he talked openly about his knowledge
of the americans concealing
evidence of
alien visitations to this planet
and all i know is i had friends of mine
who are hebrew speakers in israel reach
out to him on multiple occasions to see
if he was prepared to speak to me and he
didn't want to engage
so
whatever it was that he said
and whatever the reasons for his
unwillingness to engage
as often happens um he shut up pretty
quickly
steve cambion asks what have you
uncovered about the us government's
injection of agents and infiltration
into the ufo community for years and
what do you think their purpose is for
doing so
i'm sure that the
government and intelligence services
monitors ufo groups and look frankly i
can see some logic in that
the way it was explained to me
when you think about it during the cold
war in particular
if you were russia and you wanted to
have
an intelligence network that gave you
insights into what's going on around
some of the most sensitive bases in
america
you would be
infiltrating the
ufo groups that sit off the end of area
51 or the nevada test range or the
you know different test sites in the
sensitive parts of nevada and new mexico
it's a great way of finding out what's
going on and the evidence is irrefutable
that the russians have done that
and we've had similar things here in
australia i mean i've been briefed by
our intelligence services about
russians in caravans on holiday near
pine gap in australia or chinese people
installing weird equipment in the desert
somewhere near pine gap
and the thing that frustrates people
about pine gap is
all the
standard techniques for intercepting
data 30 or 40 years ago involved
um placing a
either a satellite or a receiver
uh into the signal from winds that was
coming from the satellite
and so you know we
quite often we'd stick
from submarines we'd stick receivers
into the line of sight of microwave
receivers for uh mobile phone telephony
in korea or
um
russia or china and that that works
still largely classified so i won't go
into a lot about it but
um
one of the things that
uh one of the reasons why pine gap was
created where it is slap bang in the
middle of australia is literally there
are thousands of kilometers of outback
desert in every direction and so it's
very hard for a a communist country or a
country that wants to spy on australia
to come and
stick a caravan or a transmitter or a
receiver under the uh
the down point of the satellites uh to
the receiving dishes in pine gap without
being caught
and there's an incredibly intensive
investigation effort by intelligence
services and defense security to make
sure that people don't uh do that and uh
so yeah i mean i hope that answers your
question anyway i've lost track of my
answer
sure sure and just so you know that
question came from steve cambion he runs
truth seekers i'll link that in the
description okay so this next question
is from not scrotus
i would love him to speculate on how
much
he thinks luis elisondo knows and what
he thinks luis alessando may say if not
for the nda and the classifications
issues classified issues in other words
how deep does ross think the rabbit hole
goes so the lewis eyes okay how much do
you think he knows
i i know that louis lozando knows a
great deal and that is because as part
of my background research into elizondo
before i approached him
i spoke to people in our special forces
who knew him from his
counterintelligence work in kandahar
with the americans during the battle of
tirankat
uh shortly after the allies invaded
afghanistan and tried to interdict
al-qaeda
louis lozando has been at the spear
point of
efforts to bring to heal the people
responsible for 9 11 for much of the
last 20 years i mean he's a cold war
warrior
and uh
what blew me away when i finally
um
checked out his bonafides was the
levels at which he'd operated when he
was based in the office of the under
secretary of defense intelligence
[Music]
before he was deployed to atip
uh
i understand and i didn't get this from
lou but i understand that he was
a liaison for defense intelligence with
the special access program oversight
committee and members of the senior
review group which
essentially if you understand anything
about how
compartmentalized intelligence in
america works
the whole country
military and intelligence services run
on a need to know basis
and
only a very small number of people need
to know the most sensitive
secrets but let me tell you somebody
who's operating at the level of the
senior review group and the special
access program oversight committee
knows a lot of the very very protected
secrets and that's about as far as i'm
prepared to go
did you see the interview that i had
with luke where he mentioned somber this
word somber okay what do you think he
not meant by the word but meant by the
implications
that the world would be somber
i i wish i could tell you what i
i'm being told right now but i don't
think it's responsible for me to talk
about it until i've been able to verify
it more because i don't want to panic
people or
be irresponsible
i'm already copying a swipe from
different people actually eric davis had
a go at me the other day because i um
i apparently talked about
[Music]
people who told me that the united
states may be actively engaged in
attempting to bring down objects by
using the frequencies that they know
these objects can be tracked at
and uh he said i was clueless on that
point and
i don't want to get a ding dong with
eric davis because i actually like the
guy and respect him enormously but
all i was doing was reporting what i've
been told
and i've been told
in another area certain things about the
phenomenon that are quite disturbing
i mean there are a lot of people
privately claiming too many
things about the implications of the
phenomenon that that go beyond far
beyond the whole notion of just i mean i
wish it was as simple as
extraterrestrials getting in their
little spaceships and flying from
zeta reticuli and coming to this planet
that's the easy explanation
the
the explanation that
i've been exploring in recent months is
more complex and i've already spoken
about this to some extent so i will say
it involves the notion of
future human
time
time travel
and look it's only hypothetical i'm not
i'm not saying it's real
but if what i'm being told about that is
true then yeah i would be somber too
why is that somber why is the fact or
the potential that it might be humans in
the future because of what it
well i think i wouldn't be giving too
much away if i said that
you think about it
why since 1947
has there been a phenomenon taking an
interest in the human race particularly
in nuclear weapons
why is something or someone
apparently trying to send us a message
about nuclear weapons
why is it that nuclear weapons are being
shut down by
what slide 9 refers to as
remote sensor disassembly
what's it trying to say
what's coming
imagine if and i'm only speaking
hypothetically here
imagine if
future humans knew that if we continue
on the path we're going there's going to
be a nuclear war or a conflagration at
some time
wouldn't you want to head that off
wouldn't you want to protect your kin
and
imagine if you were somebody in the us
defense and intelligence establishment
that was aware of that quite insane
sounding idea that this might be a
time thing
a future war thing
and imagine if you're worried that
anything you do
might
jeopardize that time stream
ah i see that's interesting
that's
where i'm
working at the moment and i don't know
if i'll ever get an answer and i'm and i
hasten to add before anybody goes off
and says cultart says blah i'm not
saying this for sure i'm just exploring
this as a hypothetical possibility
you're so amazing
i'm surmising and and that's what we
should do you know we should explore
this but a number of people have put to
me and uh
you know they've suggested to me that
this might be future human
and uh there's a great actually there's
a lovely fella michael masters uh it's
not because of his book that i'm doing
this but i commend to people michael's
explored this possibility in his
wonderful book dr michael masters
but the people that i'm talking to are
people inside the
the people who know
see when you say that it might be future
okay possibly
supposing that it might be people from
the future coming back because perhaps
we annihilate ourselves at some point
maybe there's a remnant left and they
don't want that to happen to them
this is me surmising based on what
you've said
what occurs to me is well why don't why
not be more direct about it no you may
say oh yeah one may say
okay the shutting down of nukes is
direct but absolutely i mean someone you
make my you make my day by saying that
because i've had a conversation with
somebody recently where i've said
well okay hypothetically assuming that
it is that
how do you know that being open and
transparent isn't the very thing that
would fix the trend the time stream you
know how do you know that that wouldn't
be the very thing that makes humanity go
oh my god it's real
we're going to screw up this planet if
we don't fix it
i don't know my friend i just don't know
but i mean all i'm doing is exploring
that as a surmised hypothetical
possibility
because the other thing that is possible
here is just flat disinformation
you know as i said at the very beginning
of this conversation
intelligence services lie all the time
and
one of the things as a journalist you
have to do is try and figure out what
are the what are the little nuggets in
the middle of all of that that are
possibly truthful
then how would that make sense with the
that's why i asked you earlier about the
one case where they turned it on what
would be the point of that
uh
i mean hypothetically perhaps it was to
scare the willies opposition
yeah no perhaps perhaps it was to scare
the willies out of the kremlin as much
as it scared the willies out of the
pentagon to make them realize that that
thinking of using nuclear weapons in a
defensive capacity is utterly
irresponsible and wrong
and that humanity needs to wake up to
itself and realize that we can't
continue on this course i mean the cold
war ended in 1989
i can remember as a young man i watched
a film called the day after which was a
representation in a film of what it
would look like for a nuclear war
and i genuinely i did not expect as a
teenage kid to survive the cold war i
really didn't expect to get into
adulthood
you people have forgotten
how bleak things were
you know when ronald reagan for example
was talking about the evil empire
there was talk about the strategic
defense initiative star wars you know
the russians were basically demonized
the whole soviet bloc was demonized we
didn't think of them as human we were
basically taught to think of them as
evil authoritarian communists
which
there was evil there was authoritarian
and there was nastiness but they were
human beings as well and i mean
ultimately maybe maybe at the heart of
all of this there is an intelligence
that's trying to make us think of
what we are we're human and maybe it's
in despair because we're not listening
because seriously i mean i had a
conversation with an indian journalist
just the other day talking about the
confrontations between india and
pakistan
and how there is genuine concern inside
the indian military
that
the objects that they're seeing on an
increasing basis there the the anomalous
mysterious objects that they're seeing
over their nuclear weapons
might
cause some kind of preemptive strike by
one against the other
and
you know
i know that this is a concern inside
america i mean we've we've come very
close in the past
to
almost launching nuclear weapons because
of anomalous objects seen on radar
systems
you know it is ridiculous that in this
day and age we still live and when
there's a great book the hero of the
pentagon papers daniel ellsberg
wrote a fantastic book about the work
that he did before he became the
renowned
whistleblower for the pentagon papers
that led to the revelations about the
dirty secrets the vietnam war
he was also retained by mcnamara the
defense secretary to review
the safety and the security of america's
nuclear weapons strategic nuclear
weapons
and what he found was horrifying and i
recommend i commend his book to anyone
because i think it's one of the most
important books i've read in years
because it actually showed that contrary
to what the public had been being told
generals military commanders had
delegated the decision making on the law
on the launch of nuclear weapons to
individual commanders in some locations
because they they were worried that
the way that the accountability controls
were set up for the launch of nuclear
weapons
it might not be possible to get a first
strike to get a response to strike off
if the soviets attacked and so they
delegated authority to individual
commanders to do a discretionary launch
and daniel's talked about this in his
book and i i you know it's just one of
those issues where maybe it's just too
complex for
people to talk about in mainstream media
or maybe people dismiss daniel ellsberg
as a you know a nutty cook but he's not
you know this is a highly intelligent
man who to this day
is as worried about the security of the
nuclear weapons repositories in the
united states and the soviet union china
russia britain france
india pakistan israel he's as worried
about all of these nuclear weapons now
as he was back then if not more
and we should we all should be
and and hypothetically what if what if
the phenomenon that we're now seeing in
our skies is trying to send us a message
when it goes on the radar as these
anomalous craft and it almost starts a
nuclear war does that not
contradict the
hypothesis that they're here to save us
should they not know about that
well the war didn't happen did it
maybe they were sending a message i mean
we don't know i've got no idea i mean um
there's an amazing i've i've got the
documents in my files somewhere but
i didn't put it in the book and maybe i
should have done but
there's an amazing bit of work that's
been done by a researcher in los angeles
called brad sparks about
objects that
have actually crossed
their flown directly towards
presidential uh
residences or camp david or washington
dc
and there's been clear responses it's
almost like whatever it's doing it's
it's saying
um
hey you guys you know for all of your
weapons deterrent systems we can go and
do whatever we want wherever we want
and
maybe the point of manifesting this
capacity to
the most powerful country on the planet
is
to remind them that they're still just
human
uh and that mistakes can still be made
and to
make them think twice about the um
the control and oversight procedures
that they had on the deployment of some
of the more sensitive weaponry
uh i mean one of the things i didn't
realize until i spoke to bob salas i
always assumed that somebody like bob
salas the guy who was in the icbm
minuteman silo in the 1960s
i assumed that
he
could only launch his weapons once a
code was put into his system
and then with that authorization he and
his colleague could turn the key and it
would actually work
what he explained to me was that at that
period in the 1960s
yes they required an authorization
before they were allowed to turn their
key but they could still turn their key
which which to me seems insane
that you could have two guys in a silo
in the middle of the midwest in the usa
who
if they decided to go crazy for a moment
could just simultaneously turn their
keys and cause the nuclear war
i mean the control and oversight of
nuclear weapons really is a very serious
concern and um
especially now that we've got hydrogen
bombs that the likes of which the world
has never seen used in um
[Music]
in anger and god forbid that we ever did
i mean there's a great um
i was playing with this with one of my
daughters the other night
this is what we do at home
there's a great website you can go to
where you can actually measure the
impact of certain shapes of
thermonuclear bombs on different cities
and so
the other night we were dropping bombs
on canberra and sydney and just seeing
what would happen with the radiation
over where we live
and so we decided we'd be a lot better
off if a nuclear bomb was dropped on
sydney because all the radioactive waste
would go north from where we are but if
canberra gets a bomb dropped on it which
it probably will we're completely
screwed and i i'm being flippant here
but you know the the incredible thing to
me is that as a society
humanity lives
with the ever-present reality that there
are people sitting in silos right now
with their hands on the key
ready to accept the authorization codes
to launch their nuclear weapons and
when i was with
lou elizondo in wyoming we spent a
couple of days a few days in wyoming
with him and he lives in a beautiful
part of the cowboy country there
and
he lives not too far away from the huge
mountain that featured in close
encounters as a third kind and so i i
said to him look i really apologize for
asking you this but if you've got two
hours where we can take you to
that mountain and get some pictures of
you with that iconic mountain behind you
and he very kindly agreed
and as we were driving the few hours
along the highway there and back
he started pointing out to me
tracks leading off the road
and he said what do you think they are
and i said i don't know and all i could
see was just an aerial and a what looked
like a
a gas canister or something and i said i
don't know fuel fuel bowsers or
something
and he went the icbm launched silos
and as we were driving through wyoming
my whole understanding of this beautiful
landscape changed
and i was just thinking of that scene
from terminator where new york just
explodes you know all the bombs start
going off
because we're in this beautiful
absolutely stunning cowboy country
there's mountains with snow and
you know there's literally guys with
leather chaps walking through bars you
know it's just the most gorgeous part of
the world
and then the reality that i couldn't
help but notice as we were driving along
every few miles there would be another
one of these little tracks and they're
all built the same way because the same
contractor builds them the same way
and it's just amazing to me that in this
day and age
there would have been dozens of these
tracks leading up to what
you know there's two men sitting inside
a room
ready to turn the key on the president's
orders
and just trying to think of what that
landscape would look like with icbms
coming out of the silos all over that
landscape
it's so incongruous it's such an
incredible thing i think people don't
like thinking about it but
the reality is that friends of mine that
know these things that work in
national security they say we're closer
to nuclear war now than ever before
and the international environment now is
so unstable there are so many risks that
there might be an inadvertent nuclear
attack of some kind
and we need we need to
try and avert that
and maybe just maybe there is some
intelligence that's trying to let us
know about that
have you heard of the proposition that
the aliens are concerned with us
starting a war rather than stopping a
war
that they feed off of suffering
oh god now you're getting really
depressing please give me hope i like to
uh
i like to think of benevolence
intelligence i like to think that
something that's vastly technologically
superior to us and probably more
intelligent than us has developed a
moral values system that understands the
importance of utilitarian ideas and
moral decency and ethical values
tom de long freaked me out i spent a lot
of time listening to tom delong's
interviews where he was talking about
what he'd been told
by the general and other people inside
intelligence services before he went
public with ttsa in 2016 2017
and
you know i actually think it's
really interesting because he talked
about warring gods and
jealous gods and i thought it was crazy
and then
the dnc leak happened
and it turned out that he really was
talking i mean it's beyond dart people
don't realize this and again it's just
an amazing oversight by mainstream media
that they haven't picked up on this
the leaked wikileaks emails leaked by
the russian gru believe it or not who
hacked the democratic national committee
who tried to gain intelligence that
might help trump win against hillary
clinton
the dnc emails show irrefutably that tom
delong was telling the truth
when he said that he was in
communication with generals general neil
mccaslin general michael carey
robert weiss of skunk works lockheed
martin
john podesta
and other senior officers in space
command the central intelligence agency
in different sections of the us military
were giving this punk rock rock star
briefings talking to him about what they
knew
what i find fascinating is
journalists look for evidence you look
for corroborative evidence and so i'd
listen to tom and i like everybody else
i've giggled and i thought this guy's
completely bananas you know there's one
particular coast coast interview where i
just gone nuts
and then i remember feeling very humbled
and quite ashamed of myself when i
realized oh my god and i'm going through
the dnc emails and going
hell's bells if he was telling the truth
about this
could it be he was telling the truth
about the general when the general said
it was the cold war and we found a life
form
could it be possibly true that the
general did say that to him
and if he didn't why would tom lie about
that
you know
why hasn't hillary clinton been asked
questions about this why was she clearly
clearly there were plans underway and
this is evidenced by these emails
there were plans underway by
john podesta in conjunction with certain
generals in the u.s military former and
serving
to do something about a disclosure
that's revealed in these emails they
were talking about telling the american
public something shortly after hillary
clinton became president
there was going to be some kind of
disclosure in 2017.
i just find it mind-blowing that that
you can have corroboration of the fact
that these meetings were taking place
with de long with very senior officials
he was telling the truth about that
and yet people haven't exercised the
curiosity to go well
if that was true
was tom telling the truth about warring
gods and evil aliens and
you know is that true could it be true
i think we should be asking these
questions
because something was going on and we
still don't know what it was and i just
find it mind-blowing that the new york
times the washington post
cbs abc nbc haven't gone
mrs clinton
nor stop it mrs clinton mrs clinton what
was going on what was going on why was
john podesta meeting generals why were
there talks of disclosure why are these
questions not being asked
is it just me that thinks this have i
gone crazy
what was it that tom delonge said that
freaked you out
he oh there's so many interviews you can
i mean i don't want to sound like i'm
overly promoting my book but you know
i've detailed them in my book
uh he talked about warring gods
and and i guess if you're talking about
future humans that are so
technologically advanced maybe they are
gods
but
um basically there's a
uh a conflict going on
uh and that there were evils evil aliens
that were indeed you know there were
abductions and there were
humans being killed and you know it's
quite shocking stuff
and look i wouldn't believe any of it
for a moment
or give it any kind of
airing
until i see hard evidence but the fact
that
tom was saying that contemporaneously
with all of these interviews that he was
doing he was also meeting with generals
who were telling him these things
you know he actually describes in
one of his books
how he actually
sat down he got on a private plane was
told to go to a particular airport in
the midwest somewhere
and then he met
a very senior general in a back cafe in
a diner somewhere in the middle of
nowhere
and the general basically agreed to meet
him and give him a briefing
and he really did say you know it was
the cold war we we lived in constant
fear for our lives we thought the world
was going to you know explode
and then we found a life form
and
and then what after that
uh look i i i read the book you know
seriously i don't want to i don't want
to but basically
i mean i mean that's in the description
for people who would like to buy it
so basically the um
you know tom's made a whole series of
quite elaborate claims about what he was
told incredible detail of warring alien
groups who are trying to control the
human race and
he actually said that when people came
to understand what was really going on
they would actually think that the
reasons for the secrecy were actually
quite laudable and that the public would
actually be grateful for what's being
done on their behalf and who knows they
may very well be
but um
[Music]
to this day what is it now it's um
six years
since one of tom's last interviews where
he was talking about this stuff
uh you know he obviously set up ttsa i
think in the expectation that hillary
clinton was going to be the president
and she was going to be a disclosure
president
and no matter what hillary clinton or
bill have said publicly it's quite
obvious that there were negotiations
going on behind the scenes because the
emails with john podesta show very very
clearly
there's a key one where neil mccasland
who
i mean he's two-star general who was
the guy who ran
the
what we know as the foreign technology
division at wright-patterson air force
base i mean if there is somewhere in
america where
non-human technology is being stored
hypothetically that's where that's where
it's gone
and and he was purportedly
briefing
dulong
and this is shown in these wikileaks
emails and they are leaked emails that
were never intended to be public that
were clearly regarded by the dnc as
being highly secure
and guess who leaked them the russians
the russians hacked into the dnc
leak leaking them thinking that the
exchanges might assist donald trump in
his re-election ask yourself why was why
that would have been the case
but um whatever you think of trump or
whatever you think of clinton the
reality is these conversations were
taking place
and i think that's important and it's a
piece of history that nobody has asked
questions about i've
asked frankly i've asked colleagues of
mine in
major national newspapers and tv
networks in the states why they haven't
looked at this and all of them have been
unaware of it
all of them have been unaware of the
significance of these momentous emails
where
you know it's only when you actually
look at what tom delong was saying that
he'd been briefed into the existence of
an alien spacecraft retrieval program by
members of the u.s government
that there was a back engineering
program going on underway but also at
the same time there was a war going on
between competing civilizations that
were competing for control of the human
race i mean mind-boggling stuff
uh
basically it was also talking about how
ancient there'd been previous
civilizations on this planet before
humanity arrived
and they'd been wiped out in cataclysms
and um you know a lot of the evidence of
old civilizations if you actually
analyzed them properly were not
derived from current human civilization
i mean
mind-boggling stuff and all credit to
tom frankly i am a sincere apology for
my appalling american imitation of his
american accent and my audible version
of my book but uh uh you know he he's
been proved right he's been proved right
he really was having these meetings and
when
when he appeared on
rojas coast to coast and
different um
different uh
uh
podcasts he was um laughed at you know
people derided him they says our tom
neuron's gone crazy but all credit to
him
it will appear
that from the corroboration that exists
in the wikileaks emails on at least some
points we can confirm he was absolutely
telling the truth
so what else was he telling the truth
about
what else was he being told by the us
military and more importantly
was that the truth or was it
disinformation
i mean were they using tom to get a
story out there that they knew people
would pick up on because he was a
popular figure that's always a
possibility as well you always have to
be mindful for the possibility of
disinformation now this comes from
william edwards ross what do you think
of eric davis and hal put off's
involvement with the sapphire project
and electric universe theory
well spotted
i think that's very very significant
i'm taking a very close interest in the
sapphire project because it's made a
number of claims about its technology
that frankly are more inspiring i mean
they are literally claiming that they're
getting more energy out than in at the
moment they've also claimed at different
times to
have an antigravitic effect across the
poles of the diode that they're using to
generate these plasmas these evos
i've also been concerned to see that
various
defense officials and
aerospace companies that are notorious
for covering things up have
come onto the picture and are taking an
active interest in the sapphire
technology and my worry is is that
sapphire like so many technologies
before it will disappear into the black
i hope it doesn't because it really is
quite exciting i mean i i'm i'm not a
physicist
but one of the things that i'm
fascinated by is
the growing science to suggest that
the
academic dismissiveness of what's been
called cold fusion in the past
is not entirely legitimate
and that whilst we've been looking for
many years at containing fusion
reactions in for example magnetic
tokamak reactors
that essentially magnetically constrain
a fusion reaction
it may be possible to create
self-generating plasmas
that
draw energy in a way that we don't yet
comprehend
uh from what i think hal put off calls
the zero point energy field
and look you know i'm not a physicist so
i'm not even going to try and explain
this in a scientific way but i suggest i
commend to everybody go and have a look
at the sapphire
r
s-a-f-i-r-e
project
it's
got videos that show what they've been
able to achieve
and there's some interesting analysis if
you go to the
martin fleischmann memorial project
there's been some interesting work done
by different researchers analyzing the
implications of their technology
and what fascinates me about it is it
all goes to the notion of
self-contained plasmas and there's a lot
of theoretical work that suggests that
if there's ever going to be a
breakthrough in anti-gravity
if it is possible to
uh create an
alcubierre drive you know to essentially
distort space-time and put a bubble in
front of a vehicle
that distorts space-time
and allows an object to move across the
universe by essentially going through
the fabric of space-time if that kind of
theoretical possibility which has
already been said by quantum physics to
be a theoretical possibility
is possible
perhaps one of the ways of doing this is
to use plasma technology to distort
to distort space time and perhaps that
explains the plasma hues that are often
seen on these anomalous objects that are
in our atmosphere
what was found on the moon ross
i was watching this documentary by red
red panda koala and i'll link that in
the description it's a great documentary
on tom delong and he was saying that
what happened with
the us that went to the moon that
afterward the
u.s was involved in disinformation
saying that we didn't go to the moon so
that people can
squabble over who over whether or not
the moon landing was real
and then not ask the question well what
did they find on the moon and apparently
there was
something interesting so i'm curious
what was found on the moon look uh
i
i don't know
but what i can tell you is that edgar
mitchell told
my friend the spaceman who was one of
edgar's closest personal friends
that he believed that every apollo
mission was followed up
observed while there
and followed back
and edgar even told his friend that when
he was on the moon
in the course of coming in flying the
lunar module into a landing position
on i think it's the sea of morris i
can't remember again the precise name
but um
he claimed to my friends that he saw an
object
which
funnily enough when you actually look at
the um
the film the nasa film of the lunar
module landing if you look where he says
he saw the object you can see something
that's
anomalous but he says that when they
landed and he got out of the lunar
module and was doing his walk he looked
back across to see if he could see that
object and he should have been able to
see it but he couldn't see it anymore
so um
edgar mitchell's not the only one he's
not the only astronaut and people really
should take a much closer look at this
he's not the only person who said that
he's seen stuff a lot of astronauts have
reported seeing anomalous phenomena
but frankly if there is stuff on the
moon i just don't know i'm not privy to
any secret information nobody's given me
a briefing about it but
um
certainly astronauts have reported
seeing anomalous phenomena there for
years and i i i don't think nasa has
given a full accounting of all of the
anomalous objects that have been seen
from the space station or indeed from
the gemini or apollo capsules
okay brandon irwin says heck yes you're
picking all my dream guests kurt do you
have fun reading technology
in plain sight is gold my question is
does ross think there's any substantial
there's anything substantial to tom
delong's claim that the dod
has been testing reverse engineered uap
that can disappear as claimed on his now
infamous rogan podcast in other words
has ross heard any legitimate claims
from his sources that the dod has tested
cloaking technology
look again i'm kind of nervous even
beginning to answer this question
because yet again
i preface everything i say here by
saying
i am highly skeptical of what i'm about
to tell you
i don't know whether to believe it or
not
and when i did my book research i did
what any investigative journalist does
which is i thought about how do i
protect sources that should be the first
imperative with anybody when they're
doing this kind of digging because
anybody who's talking about
what they know about the program if such
a secret program exists in the us
government you're inviting them to
breach their security guards so how do
you do that
so i knew i had phone numbers and email
addresses for a lot of people hundreds
of people that i knew
were people who if there was such a
program would probably know about it
and i did things like i looked at
members of the special access pro
special access program oversight
committee past and present members of
the dia
uh people who were cleared into certain
projects that had been written about in
academic papers and i just basically
trawled as far and wide as i looked for
names and addresses of these people
and the thing i love about america is
you're such an open society that it was
possible to get the home addresses in
many cases and so
rather than leave an electronic trail
which i knew would compromise them
immediately because it can always be
picked up the metadata is always stored
from mobile phone telephony or emails or
sms's
i or social media i
i wrote good old-fashioned letters so
for months i just wrote letter after
letter after letter after letter
and some of the people that i wrote to
were people that i had been told by
other sources were people who had worked
in what is euphemistically called the
program
they've been read into a program where
allegedly and i emphasize again i'm only
saying that this is what i've been told
i'm not saying it's real
anyway i started getting messages back
people were communicating with me on
encrypted apps or
messaging systems that
i was told to access them through
on the dark web
and they provided me with information
that
they said
the public should know
and
they asserted that there was a back
engineering program that there is
recovered multiple craft
but i got different messages about the
success of those programs i was told
that yes there have been multiple craft
recovered
but
a number of sources told me that they've
been largely unsuccessful in replicating
the technology and that indeed was the
explanation that was given to me as the
reason why the public hadn't been told
the whole story
because why would you why would you give
a strategic advantage to your rivals
your
international rivals like russia or
china by revealing the existence of this
technology when
allegedly and again i'm not saying this
is for sure but i've been told also that
the russians have recovered technology
so
that's what i've been told you know i've
been told that you know there are people
that have made claims to me that they've
been involved in the program but they've
been read into different aspects of the
program and that they've been working on
different parts of the technology
but nobody that i've spoken to has told
me that they've been able to replicate
it successfully and develop a working
anti-gravity propulsion drive or free
energy drive
and then you have these weird cognitive
dissonances with things like the patents
that were filed by the us navy by a guy
called dr salvatore pay
from the u.s navy's paxton
research laboratory in washington dc
which make completely off the wall
claims that they have operable
technology
force field generators room temperature
super conductors
trans-medium vehicles that look
alarmingly like the tic tac
you know weird fusion reactors i mean
it's it's weird stuff that's been sought
for patent applications by the us navy
and when in a number of cases they were
knocked back by the patent examiners and
queried about the validity of the
scientific claims
a letter was sent in by pays commander a
guy called sheehy
who asserted that the technology was
quote
operable
so we're at a really interesting period
in history right now where an arm of the
u.s defense department has asserted that
it has cracked this technology
publicly though we're being told
nothing about it
yet at the same time
we're also witnessing a phenomenon in
on our planet which is inexplicable
it is not matching known human
technology
so that's why i still think it's
possible that this might be black world
technology maybe we've cracked it maybe
when we went black with anti-gravity in
the 1950s and the 1960s we really did
crack it
i don't know
i just don't know so i mean have you
spoken to salvador
oh believe me i've tried
yeah i've tried it i i think the only
person who's been able to get a
communication going with him is brett
tingley from the drive the warzone
online blog
and he did a very good job brett to
secure that and uh salvatore pay
defended the validity of his patents and
asserted that his technology was
genuinely operable
uh but every physicist that i've spoken
to told me that it's complete pie in the
sky [ __ ] that
none of it's for real
now modern science has been wrong before
you know i think the the notion of an
incredible weapon that could split the
atom would have been inconceivable to
many scientists back in the 1940s and
yet we were working on it in secret in
the manhattan project
project unity wants me to ask you about
nat colbitz
good on uh good on project unity it's a
great site um
nat cobits
who became a very solid friend of mine
was the director of science technology
development for the us navy
uh sadly he was one of the people i
wrote to and i honestly in my dreams
would never have expected that somebody
with his seniority would
write back but one day out of the blue
he just literally contacted me and
we started having conversations and we
spoke for quite a while
but it was obvious to me that he was
dying he had cancer and his family
explained to me that he had terminal
cancer
and i think that affected his
willingness to discuss
what he discussed
because there came a time when i asked
him that
were you ever read into were you of a
security briefed
into
alleged
alien
craft retrieval
back engineering programs
and it's funny because i was just
getting ready to move on because there
was a pause you know i you know it was a
big pregnant silence
and then all of a sudden he came back
and said
yes
but i was never read out of it so
there's not much i can say
and
so began the most extraordinary
period of discussions a lot of which i a
lot of which i haven't put in the book
because i don't think i have any right
to but
he
introduced me to a wide range of people
who
asserted that they were aware of
the program
nat had never personally seen these
quote multiple craft himself
but because of who he was he was
essentially the chief research geek for
the us navy he was read into them
and uh he
he did tell me that on one occasion
after he'd left the navy when he was
working in his private company in k
associates nka
he was an expert in a type of welding
called electron beam welding
ebw
which is a type of welding
for bonding two different types of metal
and very very high strength apparently
they do the under they do the
undercarriage for the c5 galaxy for
example that was his speciality bonding
metals
and uh he got a phone call from
what you and i would know as the foreign
technology division of the wright
patterson air force base you know the
apocryphal car park for ufos
and um he was flown to right pat and
taken into a secure
area and he told me that he was shown
a
section of bulkhead several feet wide
several feet square
and he said he couldn't explain what
that bulkhead was but it was clearly
from quote a craft it looked like a
fractured piece of metal from a craft
but he could see it was two types of
metal
and he was allowed to examine it they
wanted his opinion about how it had been
bonded they thought it might have been
bonded using electron beam welding
but when he looked at it microscopically
he could see that it was bonded
at the atomic level to use his words he
said it was beyond anything he'd ever
seen he'd never seen bonding like that
it was like the the atoms had been
layered
in a way that he couldn't explain and he
said he wish he knew how that technology
worked because it was fantastic
and that was all he ever saw
but basically this is an official of the
us government a very senior member of
the u.s navy
claiming that he was briefed into a
crash retrieval program and that on one
occasion he still maintained his
security oath
he was briefed into a
viewing of a piece of bulkhead
and i said to him i said was it alien
and all he would do is just laugh and he
said you know i'm a scientist you know i
deal in what i know all i know is i
couldn't explain what that was
and he said to this day i still can't
explain what that um
how that whip and how that
metal was bonded
but what was enormously useful was he
kindly
graciously
facilitated introductions for me to
other people who are the primary sources
that
i've developed an opinion
based on what they told me
and they are the people who then went on
to talk about the existence of an
ongoing back engineering program
involving multiple craft
and i still
shake my head when i say that because it
just seems incomprehensible to me as an
investigative journalist
with some reputation i'm even talking
about this stuff because i'm worried
about being ridiculed or
attacked for even saying it
but
ultimately i'm using the same objective
fact testing that i use as a journalist
with any other story and i'm inexorably
led
to a conclusion that prima facie on the
facts i have a suspicion that the united
states does have multiple recovered
craft
and especially when you look at the
context of comments made by people good
people like dr eric davis
and others
including senator harry reid who's kind
of wavered a bit from time to time
because i think he's been reminded of a
security oaths as a member of the gang
of eight
something's going on
you know i'm not satisfied that we don't
have i can't rule out
that we have this technology or the
americans have got this technology
hidden somewhere in a basement
and i find it mind-boggling that
defense aerospace national security
reporters aren't asking the question
and i noticed in the period coming up to
the uap task force report
you might be able to find it on the web
there was one
very enterprising journalist who
unusually had the call at the pentagon
press briefing to actually ask is the
u.s i think the question was you know is
the u.s hiding alien spacecraft you know
do you have recovered alien spacecraft
and rather than answer the question
rather than just dismiss it parentally
as you would expect a pentagon spokesman
to do
what really struck me
was how he just avoided the question
and said we'll have to wait for the
findings of the uap task force
really interesting
and you've got to also see that in the
context of comments that have been made
by people like
donald trump i mean you know frankly
as far as i can see trump was completely
open about most things in his government
and there was a really revealing
interview that he did
with donald trump jr his son
in the months running up to the
election
and don junior asked his father
so dad you know a lot of us want to know
you know what about what about roswell
you know what there's all these claims
about alien craft and stuff like that
you would expect the president of the
united states to go ah come on sonia
don't worry my time with that bs
but no trump gave it currency he gave it
validity he said that's a very
interesting story
and he acknowledged that he'd like to
reveal more about that
go figure
okay this question comes from dom to
long
what have you heard from a credible
source that was too incredible for you
to make the leap and include it in your
book
uh i'm not gonna go there i got into
trouble just the other day for for
reporting something that i've been told
by somebody about
the us using
its knowledge of
craft frequencies to bring down craft
and uh i got bollocks for that so i'm
not gonna go there i'm sorry i do know
some pretty amazing things and i've been
told some amazing things but frankly i'm
i'm um i'm feeling the sting right now
of
ufo twitter that frankly doesn't seem to
understand that when people are talking
about things that they've been told by
people it doesn't necessarily mean that
i'm saying it's for real
so um yeah frankly uh
not going there
for roz delaware wants or delaware wants
to know what does ross know about the
majestic 12 the majestic 12 and secret
alien bodies in 40s and 50s
i just don't know
i mean i've like everybody i've read
about the mj 12 claims
one of the things that
fascinates me is
if there is
a secret being kept
and if there are a group of people in
the u.s government that are keeping the
secret
and i think there is
then somebody is somebody is obviously
running a uh
a disinformation effort somebody is
obviously coordinating who gets told
what
somebody's running it
um
i don't think it's called mj-12 the most
recent iteration i was told was zodiac
but
again i think that's been overtaken by
events as well because that name became
public
[Music]
there must be people in positions of
power in the united states government
who are briefed into the program if the
program exists
if the program exists
um
but certainly
i am more than happy to say that i think
that there are people in the u.s
government who know a lot more than
they're letting on about the phenomenon
and yes there is a group that is
coordinating what we're told about that
and uh i guess i can understand that to
some degree you know you wouldn't if
it's a matter of national security you'd
want to guard it quite carefully
but is there a sinister body that is
controlling what we know for nefarious
reasons
god i hope not
i mean i one thing i love about
america is that for all of its faults
there's still a streak of moral decency
that runs through
its government you know it has
principles constitutional principles
that it holds dear at least to pay slip
service to
i mean
god forbid if this technology exists god
forbid that it falls into the hands of
authoritarian dictatorships like russia
or china
i mean
if there is technology or information
that the world is on the cusp of
learning i hope it's done
through the auspices of a democratic
country that has respect for individual
human rights and liberty
because you wouldn't want technologies
that
have been described to me and
of which we're now aware in the hands of
the wrong people
question to ross from euphoric gir 4674
as a journalist who understands we
didn't get all these names so i'm gonna
have to change my name my name is far
too boring this is
[Laughter]
sorry
question to ross as a journalist who
understands the news cycle and you know
that the general public jumps from topic
to topic what can we
do
i'm assuming he means as the public as
the people watching this what can we do
to keep the ufo story in the headlines
until the truth comes out in other words
how do we not lose the momentum on this
topic
oh boy that's a really good question i
don't think people out there realize how
powerful they are
i mean really
i've i've sat in the offices of
ministers of government and seen how
they overreact to a dozen letters on an
issue
you know ministers staffers panic when
they get letters
a good old-fashioned handwritten typed
letter that says i want you to
investigate blah i'm a i'm a voter i i
influence a large number of people in
the electorate that i'm in which just so
happens to be a marginal electorate i
want you to do something about this you
know you're my political representative
act do something now
and so i really think the simplest thing
that people can do is let their
political representatives know that this
issue matters to them
i mean i you know you've got elections
at the moment in canada uh and at the
moment the big question is will trudeau
survive government why aren't people
asking him on the campaign trail mr
prime minister have you been read into
anything pertaining to uaps why isn't
the legitimate question when the united
states government has admitted that the
phenomenon is real
you know what's the cognitive dissonance
here that means that even though the
pentagon has now acknowledged the
phenomenon is real
it cannot explain prosaically this
phenomenon
the mainstream media still to a large
degree treat it with a ridicule and
contempt
kind of a taboo and stigma
it has to change and
ultimately what people need to do is
get on the blower but don't do it in a
nutty way
you know say to a journalist excuse me
you're the national security writer for
the globe and mail or the national
security writer for the new york times
um why did you pooh-pooh the whole issue
of ufos and that article you wrote the
other day you know why are you not
taking it seriously when the us
government is
you know are you aware of this issue
this issue and this issue that
legitimizes why this is a legitimate
area for investigation
hey have you read the book in plain
sight by ross coulthard
but um more importantly the other thing
you can do is
get on the blower or write actually
writing's really important a physical
letter makes a huge difference it could
be type of statement but as long as it's
print types yeah people should just get
on their typewriter and write well what
do they use these days their laptop and
write a letter
i grew up in journalism when you
actually did
carbons this is how old i am you wrote
carbons of your story and so i have to
have four bits of carbon paper and then
type on a typewriter of my story and
then i'd put a pin through the paper
and send different copies off to
different editors that's how we
circulated stories
and um
you know it's amazing these days because
we now live in a in an
age where it's very easy to distribute
information
but that old-fashioned way of
distributing information in a letter i
found it an extraordinarily powerful
research tool when i was writing my book
because it was a way of
protecting sources because snail mail to
a large degree is not intercepted still
it is intercepted sometimes but not as
much as
emails or other forms of electronic
communication
and so
there's enormous power in writing a
letter to a minister of government
saying
what
or even you know for example if you're a
tv reporter or
just an activist journalist
politely you know don't be nasty about
it respectfully i found the best way is
to be respectful and honorable to people
and give them a break
you know get a camera next time you know
hillary clinton somewhere say oh this is
clinton hi my name's joe blogs i'm a
citizen podcast activist interested in
ufos
she might start walking away can i ask
you what you were talking to
john podesta about in 2016.
you know what were you talking about
when you said in in this email blah blah
blah blah blah
you know people need to ask the nuts and
bolts questions we need to drill down
and actually do some serious research
for example just the other day i am i've
written a letter to a guy who
claims in a book
that jfk wrote a memo on the 12th of
november
1963 that asked the director of the cia
to
collate
ufo information that was sensitive for
national security so that it could be
shared with the russians
now i hasten to wear
he claimed the writer claims that he'd
obtained that memo on freedom of
information from the cia
and there was an article that was
published in the media that said
immediately
that the provenance of that memo was in
question because when they checked at
the jfk library they couldn't find any
such memo
and so you were left at the end of all
of the articles that were published
about this guy's book with the
impression that that 12th of november
1963 memo was a fake it was a hoax
either he was hoaxed or you know
somebody had done it
so i thought back at this i want to know
so i tracked down the guy last night and
i've emailed him and i've if i don't
hear from him i'll post him a letter but
i want to know i want to ring him and
find out what the hell's going on what's
the truth of that claim did he actually
foi and did he obtain that document on
foi
and if i can find out that he did obtain
that documentation on foi
why then were all these articles written
in the media
asserting that it couldn't be a real
document
who instigated those articles was it
disinformation
so that's the way my brain works you
know i'm an investigative journalist and
so i don't take any fact for granted i
have to test those facts and and verify
verify them for myself
and um
that's where i'm at basically i'm
constantly checking things and so people
should do that so one of the things that
has come up a bit in today's
conversation is people have often said
you know what do you think about blah
and
a lot of that is unverifiable you know i
can't verify alien abductions or
experiences i can't
but if there are specific incidents like
you know one of the things that i have a
b in my bonnet about is the way that
nasa never responds have you noticed
this they never respond to those weird
shots there's one in particular that
gets my imagination going
of an object that's shot from the space
station or from a
spacecraft of some kind looking down on
the planet and what you see is an object
that's moving along and then a light
flashes from the planet below and
interestingly enough it's over north
western australia which is why i'm
interested in it and the object reacts
before the light hits it and then just
goes
and moves off
now i haven't seen i have what can i say
look it's in the in endless numbers of
nasa space objects i'm sure some of your
listeners will know about it before the
end of this conversation they will have
posted it
but it really does look amazing and so
i've approached nasa or i've approached
different space experts and i've said
can anybody explain this
now
because i'm not in america or i'm not
able to go to nasa archives i can't go
and verify
that particular piece of film from
i think it was the space shuttle
uh to see whether or not it really was
on that sts on that particular space
shuttle mission
but people need to do the work to
actually go okay
here is a potential mystery here's an
issue that can be investigated let's
drill down and test the provenance of
the claims that have been made about
this video
what if we can show that it is a real
nasa video
then we go to a defence reporter on a
major national newspaper and we say okay
we've done the homework for you because
most of these reporters don't have the
time this is the reality from my time in
commercial television we're working in
freeway most of them don't have the time
to do this kind of grunt investigative
journalism
if you go to them and say hey listen
this is the work we've done we're a ufo
transparency group you may think we're
crazy but have a look at this these are
the source documents from nasa we've
gone to nasa's own archives this film
came from this
time period in this shuttle mission
here's the proof you can find it on this
file in this archival document on the
nas's files
look at it
what's that like what's that
objectivating what the hell's going on
here
you know the thing that irritates me is
the number of times things get posted
onto the web
by people who think they're doing the
right thing in ufology
and they haven't done the basic checks
before they put it up there and then
immediately what happens is somebody
just goes oh yeah that's [ __ ]
and it dies
dies on the vine
what people need to do is become
cleverer
they need to test the evidence first
before they put it up there and so
that's why frankly i have a lot of
trouble with the blurry videos of
distant objects that people endlessly
post on the web because they can be
faked so easily they're so useless
they're so helpless
but what if you can go back through
as i know you can
[Music]
and this is interesting edgar mitchell
sat on a couch with my friend the
spaceman
and showed him
the original
digitized nasa films of the lunar
landings
and pointed out to him things that he
edgar said were anomalous
and i've seen them i've sat there with
the spaceman and watched them and gone
[ __ ] he's right
and
this is the thing that really blows me
away is there could be a whole area of
ufo investigation that actually
seriously engages with the content that
nasa itself has broadcast
and when nasa refuses to answer go to
your congressman and say
sorry can we get a question posed please
at the senate armed services committee
or at the nasa oversight committee can
we get a question asked about why
they're refusing to answer questions
from citizens who are paying their tax
bill
because people forget these are publicly
funded organizations they are
accountable to you the public
you own them
they're yours they may not like
admitting that but they're your
institutions they have to be accountable
to you and one of the things that to me
just greats as a journalist is that
people don't understand their rights to
ask
they might refuse
but if they do refuse you put that up in
lights nasa has refused to answer a
reasonable question about x y and z
why
then you go to your next congressman and
you say well you're senator and you say
senator will you ask a question in the
federal congress about you know why
nasa's refusing to answer questions but
you turn it into a huge issue
i mean look at the momentum that was
developed for that stupid raid area 51
thing you know people people thought
right well remember that
yeah imagine if instead of raid area 51
it was
nasa tell the truth
you know explain these videos explain
the anomalies
imagine if there was a sensitive
scientist a sensible scientific
engagement with the anomalous objects
that have repeatedly been cited on nasa
missions
many of which nasa has
not been able to explain
well we'll see if we can get that
popularized this hashtag nasa tell the
truth after
once this video is reposted
now kurt you've exhausted me mate so i
really don't know how much longer i can
go yeah okay well then how about let's
break it down into three steps for the
people who are watching just the
audience not journalists okay so what
should they do first search google for
local represent like what are they let's
break it down into three concrete steps
what do they do
okay
don't be insulting
political representatives are just going
to throw your letter in the mail if
you're rude or impolite or if you come
across as a crazy person
so be respectful
ask
don't just dash off a stupid email that
doesn't ask a question write a really
cleverly considered carefully written
letter
so for example let's just use as an
example than nasa objects
somebody needs to go to the nasa
archives and search those archives for
the film vision that is regularly posted
up on youtube saying you know where
somebody says hey look at this now
shuttle mission sts-16
at 21 minutes 30 there's a object that
does x y and z somebody needs to go and
prove that in the files and prove that
and get the actual data and write it all
out do the research so maybe there's
somebody here from florida who can go
and sit down in nasa and or in houston
or wherever it is do that research
collaborate
and this is the thing i've learned as a
journalist i'm a member of this group
called icij where we for example
investigated the panama papers the
leaked papers that showed who was
evading tax by having
tax shelters in the bahamas and other
places like that and we all collaborated
so there was a guy in belgium who could
do a property search for me in belgium
and i could do a lunch title search in
sydney and we could share data it's cool
it's a really cool thing to do
you guys can do this in the world of
uaps ufos you can share data
be intelligent don't just shove a bloody
video up and go oh look what i found i
beat everybody else to it by putting it
up here and then it immediately gets
shot down in flames
don't put it up there until you've
verified its provenance
if you can
so you know go to nasa get the data and
then put together a considered letter
dear senator
please find attached uh an mpv file or
whatever wv file which shows vision of
an object that was shot from the space
shuttle endeavour on blar date on
blah time
on this mission
i know this and i can verify this
because
this is the file number of where this is
stored in the nasa archive and i have
this proved copy of that data which i
obtained from nasa under foi
i put it to you sir that this shows an
anomalous intelligently controlled
object maneuvering in our orbit
and it is clearly a space vehicle of
some kind
that is not human
can i please ask why this is not being
investigated if there is a legitimate
national security reason for why we're
not being told the truth about this can
this please be explained to me
i am representative of an organization
that represents 5 000 people um you know
maybe it's move on i don't know
uh
you know please sir kindly could i
request that you direct your questions
to this the next meeting of the nasa
oversight committee you know this is how
you do it
be respectful
you never know
the mood in the congress at the moment
is really interesting i'm talking to
congressmen senators and their staffers
they're waiting for
the public
to show they want this
because i don't think it's going to
happen i'm not of the view that there's
going to be transparency any more than
we've got at the moment i think we've
been sold a pub
i think that the uap task force
really only largely came about because
of the activism of the ttsa people
good people like louis lozando
christopher mellon
and tom de la
what he's done is amazing all credit to
tom frankly what he's done is absolutely
amazing he's brought this ahead far more
than i think anybody realized he ever
would
but there's nothing going to happen
there's certainly not going to be public
hearings or congressional hearings
unless the public make it clear
intelligently
and firmly that they do want it and that
these are the reasons why and these are
the things that should be investigated
so when people send me experience of
videos and say you know i've seen this
object hovering at 20 000 feet and all i
see is a white dot moving across the sky
what the hell am i meant to do with that
no no disrespect to the people that sent
it to me but seriously i can't verify
its provenance i don't know what you've
done with it
but let's think intelligently let's look
at the things that we know come from
government itself like for example the
nibitz sighting
you know we know for a fact that the
reason why the government's been forced
into the position that it's been paused
into at the moment it's largely because
of the um incredible work that was done
by different people to expose what was
revealed in the nimitz data
and the reason that why that was so
efficacious because there is clearly
vision
which was confirmed by sensor systems
and what i've been told uh bob fish who
was one of my informants that went on
the record in my book he's a guy with
extremely high security clearances who
is aware of the reality of the
phenomenon he's been briefed about
anomalous objects that have been seen on
satellites and
seen coming in and out of the ocean he
tells me
he told me that people should be looking
at the um
the data the the kind of data that would
be being collected by
um
the e2 hawkeye aircraft you're talking
about telemetry data um
not just radar data you're talking about
very high level uh electromagnetic data
communications data measuring the
frequencies of those objects
that telemetry data would exist and
nobody apparently has foider let's say
for why that
so there are ways of investigating this
in a in a rigorous scientific
objective way and as best i can i'm i'm
asking questions myself
but i am a little frustrated with the
tendency on ufo twitter for people to
seize across every new crazy rumor
and it's really not helping frankly it
just paints you all as a bunch of bloody
loonies and you're not i know you're not
you know there is something real there
the government's confirmed that it's
real
but by continuing just to post blurry
videos and
you know uncorroborable uh witness
accounts it's really not helping
what people need to do is become far
more methodical and clever
and and it's interesting because
if you look at your history
way back in the 1950s
the people who were driving the push for
disclosure the lou elizondos and the
christopher mellons of their day
they included people on nycap
like
roscoe hillenkotter a former director of
the central intelligence agency
why the hell was a former director of
the cia
actively pushing for disclosure by the
u.s government of what it knew about the
phenomenon
clearly he believed that the us was
hiding something 70 years ago
and here we are
70 years later
and it's the same old cycle
so it's very very easy to think that it
might be possible that we're just being
bought off with another lame
promise that they're going to do some
kind of ufo oversight inside the
congress or inside the office of the
under secretary of defense intelligence
but that the the secret the real secrets
will be kept for another 50 to 100 years
i wouldn't be surprised at all if they
were because people aren't pushing
they're not using the powers that they
have in the congress to actually demand
that the congressman ask questions and
they need to ask arm their congressman
and congresswoman with the sort of
questions that need to be being asked
and they need to be intelligent
questions not dumb whack-up job
questions that make people sound like
loops
no no and try and limit the number of
stamps you put on the envelope because
if it's more than four stamps i
generally think you're crazy
and sorry i'm not being flippant here
but you know the uh well i am being
clifford but i mean i i do think there's
a serious message here is that the
ufology needs to wake up to itself
it is right i mean people get angry with
um
skeptical questioning by people like
john greenwald of the black vult i'm a
fan of john i love what he does and he
he should be answering asking questions
you know and and mick west for example
god bless him the don quixote of
skeptics tilting at that windmill but
you know we need people like that it's
really important that that
the claims made be tested
and i've been pulled up on a few things
where people have said to me well how do
you know that you know they're using uh
the frequencies that they can detect
these objects by to bring them down
because i've recently talked about the
fact that
there is
stories that are uncorroborated that the
united states might be trying to think
about bringing down one of these objects
and even though i've said it a hundred
times
i don't know it
i don't but what i'm reporting is what
i've been told
and sometimes maybe it's not a good idea
to report those things maybe it's better
just to keep your mouth shut let's deal
objectively with what we do know
what we do know is that there is a
phenomenon that is unexplained
and it's been admitted to be unexplained
by the most powerful country on the
planet
there are objects that appear to be
intelligently controlled craft that are
maneuvering
hypersonic maneuvers
they're capable of doing all manner of
weird things
and the government admits
it's real
that's a pretty good start for people to
start writing to their congressman and
demanding action
demanding oversight hearings
and one of the things that they'll be
very very sensitive about is the
questions about the black budget
because really in the last 30 years not
much has come out of area 51
and yet trillions of dollars have been
spent in the black budget
where u.s taxpayers if they actually
added it all up have no bloody idea
where their money's gone
there are literally
dozens
hundreds of black projects where money's
been sunk into things and the public
haven't been told what it was for
now for all their faults
the one thing the generals are worried
about the one thing the people spending
the money are worried about is having to
account for that money
and believe me
when the questions asked they will have
to answer
so it's the good old political maximum
the will that squeaks gets to greece if
you want action to happen you have to
become
it's not enough just to bleat on social
media
not going to work
if you've got the time to sit down and
pin some poisonous venom on social media
for half an hour
why not just sit down and find out the
name of your political representatives
and write to them
and say this matters to you
and i'm not crazy
you know i'm a i'm a doctor or a lawyer
or a businessman and i actually think
that there is something really serious
behind this phenomenon and i want you my
political representative to take it
seriously i want transparent open
hearings in the congress and if not why
not and this will affect my vote
end of letter
i like that okay ross thank you so much
you've
been extremely generous with your time
i'm gonna say goodbye to the audience
and then we'll just speak for a minute
off air
sure lovely to talk to you
goodbye everyone thank you so much
there's been i think a thousand people
at its max and it's been hovering at
around 850 people constantly so thank
you
i'm gonna stop the stream and then ross
let's
talk
i asked ross to give me three steps that
those who are interested in the ufo
phenomenon can take in order to get the
government to release more information
on this topic
he sent me seven steps
here they are number one pick an issue
pertaining to uaps that offer an
opportunity to perhaps independently
verify or debunk the claims made about
it for example in the case of sts-48
that is the 1991 shuttle mission there's
been a plethora of claims on the
internet with debunkers saying it's
clearly ice and the conspiracists
asserting its et
number two to the end of resolving the
matter assess whether it adequately
explains all the issues raised by the
evidence in this case i've read the
popular science explanation by james
oberg
but nothing adequately addresses the
flash of light you see at a considerable
distance from the shuttle
what could this be
number three
let's obtain the original data in this
case it would be nasa's own vision and
the other data james oberg cites in his
paper number four assess the data and
see if there are unanswered questions
remaining if there are unanswered
questions then number five write a
polite and careful letter to your
congressman congresswoman
setting out why you believe this is an
unresolved mystery that is worthy of
official engagement by your political
representative number six if this letter
gets ignored publish your research
efforts online and show people the
efforts you've made to verify the
reality behind the observed phenomenon
this is extremely important this is
kurt's note now this step is the most
important because otherwise we'll have
people saying well look i've reached out
well what's your evidence that you've
reached out you're asking for them to
provide evidence how about you provide
some evidence that you've actually done
the work and have filed let's say an foi
claim or have sent a physical letter to
a congressperson then ross says that the
number seven step which is the last step
is move on to the next claim best wishes
and warm thanks ross coltart
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you